We are good.
We are alive.
Fuck yeah.
Brian Callen ladies.
Gentlemen.
Brian counts in the building.
This is episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by stamps.com
stamps.com stamps dot.
That's my laptop.
Been doing this forever.
Never shut that fucking thing off in time.
Is it okay buddy?
Right?
It's all right.
Especially if you're in Houston.
I can never,
is that what you're promoted?
Especially if you in Houston at the Improv this weekends and like Brian
[inaudible],
I am the worst.
We're going to talk about it.
You're going to help me with my self promotion.
Well,
you're not bad out of it.
You just don't do it.
You just get lazy.
I just get,
I just like,
what am I gay?
Everybody come into Houston Improv Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
This Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
Brian Callan two shows.
Friday two shows Saturday.
That's absolutely the wrong way to do it.
Oh,
sorry.
Is it I need you to help me.
It doesn't matter.
As long as you just say just a little bit of the lower register.
I'm going to be very funny.
Old Lady is,
is just trying to get someone to come see something.
Awesome.
Thank you.
And I'm,
I'm very,
I'm very proud of my,
my,
my current one hour.
It's coming together very.
You killed me when we're working in Toronto.
Had a great fucking time.
It was really fun.
It's a girl killed me too.
He's funny.
Well I was saying as the query did my podcast yesterday and I was saying to him,
dude,
you're one of the few people you know,
look,
I've been doing it a long time.
I did.
We had a great time,
but I got to move around.
I'm pulling rabbits out of a hat,
you know,
cigrow can stand still and just one place and crush a role.
Like he just stands there.
Like he's really good.
He's great going really good.
I'm good.
I'm in the way of your promotion.
Let's go.
I know it's such a big deal this weekend,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday,
Brian Collins and the kid Callen clarity will end ends.
This is the audience.
Hopefully they're laughing.
They're like,
you're friends with Joe Rogan,
so it was brought to you by stamps.com if you have a business and you do it from
your home,
stamps.com is an excellent resource for you.
It allows you to like say if you're sending things out,
like Brian sends those death squad tee shirts out through death squad.tv.
Those are all his,
his artwork.
He makes himself and he sends them all himself with stamps.com super easy to do.
You weigh out what you're sending a year.
You have a a computer scale that they give you a digital scale they give you
with uh,
this,
this code j r.
E.
It's $110 offer that it gives you $55 of free postage and a digital scale and
you can just print the postage stuff right off of your home computer.
You put it on your package,
the post man comes,
he takes it and you're done.
It's crazy.
It's,
it's actual like postal stamp.
I've never done that.
I've got to start doing that.
Well,
it's a great thing if you send things frequently.
It's really amazing.
If you send thing frequency it frequently,
it keeps you from having to do that thing where you go to the post office knew
Wayne Line,
oh my God,
and there's 10 people like you in front of you and that lady does not want to
have none of this.
She's not pleasant.
It's just not,
I'm just waiting for politics to become con.
I'm just waiting for one candidate to get elected because he was able to do it
through social media from his garage and not have to rely on the power structure
of fundraising,
but it's probably going to happen,
but I don't know what the fuck that let's do@stamps.com why Jesus Christ.
She just went crazy.
It's Fox News on May hats.
Dot Fox News.
The opposite was Rt.
I dunno if our teas the opposite.
What's the opposite?
It's not CNBC,
right?
I think Fox News is guilty of anybody as anybody else having an ideology and
being unfair in the way they,
they,
you know,
couch things.
In my opinion,
use the code word GRE.
It's 110 bucks off stamps.com by the way,
the Joe Rogan experience.
So if your phone son Joe Rogan experience podcast does not support nor indoors,
the wacky ideas and Mr Kellen promotes stamps.com does not without a doubt,
does not support nor acknowledge the wacky ideas.
Mr Kellen was talking about some sort of overthrowing the government.
We don't know what it was there to sell packages and let you do it through the
fucking email.
Join my order.
Use the code word Jerry,
stamps.com excellent,
excellent service.
We're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Another excellent service.
I don't know Bryan County have ever been involved in anything like starting up
your own corporation or writing got,
we'll have him just start at one.
Just started one for the fighter and the kid.
Another podcast I have on Fox,
which Brendan Shop I ever stop.
I don't play around.
I talk UFC and we're crushing it on Fox,
the fighter and the kid.
This is insane.
Keeps calling you have too much success.
I had to incorporate because we're going to make us sick.
Someone's success in your life.
Thank you,
dude.
Bought a new car too.
Oh yeah.
Folks.
Wagon facade,
TD,
high turbo diesel,
40 miles to the gallon.
That's car I've ever had.
Very solid.
You make me so sad.
Anyway,
legal zoom.com
you can incorporate it form an LLC.
Started getting 99 bucks.
You can.
You can make a will.
You can protect your family assets with a will from legal zoom for 69 bucks.
That's crazy,
dude.
Hold on.
You can.
You can start an incorporation.
I paid $1,300 to incorporate and legal zoom.
You can do it for,
you can do it at,
it starts at $100 Oh my God.
Yeah.
You can get a will for 69 bucks.
It's amazing.
There's a lot of shit that you would normally have had to do.
I mean,
there's a lot of things that you may still have to do with the lawyer.
Did they have staff that can help you then?
They do.
This is one of the beautiful things.
If you,
if you get to a certain point and you're going through this,
which by the way,
Brian used it more than once.
Okay,
so I read Pan Fry bread.
It's funny how you're like Brian and Ryan.
Here's Dad.
Listen,
Brian will tell you he's not,
you know,
the,
the most studious or well-read young man on earth.
He's,
you know,
kind of,
he flies that flag and he used it easily so it's a red band can read.
Ben's not nearly as dumb as people think.
Yes,
I didn't say this is more of an act on anything.
It's just a silly boy.
He's a funny,
silly boy.
He's sick today.
We're hoping he goes to a fucking doctor.
Hasn't eaten in days.
It's good.
You might want to do something there.
Yeah,
man.
Too much party.
No Bueno,
no Bueno,
no Bueno.
Too much party.
The body wants to break.
Oh,
good for you.
Go to legal zoom.com.
Use the code Rogan in the referral box and you can save some cash.
They,
they do have the ability to connect you to an independent attorney if you need
additional guidance to,
if you're going through the process,
you know,
like,
you know what,
I'm a fucking chicken shit.
I feel like I'm doing something wrong here.
I don't want to go to jail or whatever or have something being valid or
whatever.
And so if you need extra help in that way or if you need,
just need extra help with whatever the hell you're incorporating with you can,
you can do that.
They'll connect you with an independent attorney and uh,
the online process couldn't be easier.
They'll take care of you start to finish.
It's,
it's very easy to deal with.
And again,
legal zoom is not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your specific direction.
So get it together.
Bryan County,
I spent 1300 bucks on that shit.
I'm trying to learn.
I'm trying to be more computer savvy.
I had Alexis Ohanian,
I the guy who created Reddit,
if I'd read it on the podcast.
Yeah.
Brian Gallant choosing another bobcat's Brian,
you have a your own podcast.
I can't keep up with no dude.
Have a 10 minute thing too.
Yeah,
there is dude,
I don't,
I have three podcasts.
If you guys want to laugh and learn and be inspired and turn,
turn,
go.
When,
when,
when Rogan's not doing his Brian,
the kid Callan's around,
but very good at it.
You're,
you could talk for days too.
I love doing it,
man.
I love it.
And I,
and I'm getting people like this guy I like says,
oh honey founded reddit and we were just talking about how I have such an
aversion as you know,
to anything.
Like anything computer.
I'm like writing code.
I start to panic immediately and he was like sweat too.
It's like I could teach you that,
you know,
it's not that hard then these blown you.
That's how it works.
How this works,
found founder,
I've read it costs me a fortune to have them blow me.
Um,
I asked,
I asked him what he does with his money.
I go,
you know,
you've made a 30 year old guy,
so really good guy.
Go,
he made a lot of money.
What are you doing?
He goes,
I upgraded my Redskins tickets.
Uh,
I got,
my dad's a huge fan,
so I sit right behind the visitor's bench and I like to shout at them.
I like to shout and get into their head.
He just didn't salts the other team,
that's the first thing he did with his money so he could go on and salt.
Anybody who plays the Redskins and he and his dad sit there and he sits there
and goes,
how many kids do you have?
How many?
What's your paternity bill like?
I mean he just kills him.
Oh my God.
Like the one dude Cooper who's wide receivers started reddit.
Yeah.
That he's a really funny guy.
And he goes around the country talking to colleges and basically saying to these
kids,
Hey,
everything that you know,
like higher education and the way you're supposed to do shit,
it's no longer really relevant anymore.
All that matters is what you can do.
And there's a whole wide open out there for you
to think outside the box.
And it's kind of like his mission,
you know?
But he was talking about how he was on,
he's this Guy Cooper who was at a Justin Bieber concert with saying some racial
shit.
You know,
he's a white wide receiver saying racist stuff about black people.
He gets behind the bench and he's basically shouting at Cooper going,
Cooper,
do you still feel that way?
What's it like to be in the locker room with all these black people who are
around you?
And,
and,
and his teammates were all laughing and making fun of them.
They were kind of like snickering and stuff.
So that's what he does with his money.
Brian Cowen will be at the Houston Improv this weekend and buffalo the next
week.
Brian callen.com and it never ends.
I guess we should play some music on it.com use the code name.
Rogan save 10% off any and all supplements.
Do we,
do we get new?
Any Eddie kettlebells yet?
Do we get you the crime?
Will Bells Dude?
No.
And I need some,
I'm going to ask you,
you need the primal,
but I've been asking you since I saw the prototype.
We'll contact Aubrey this afternoon after this podcast is over and we will get
some problem bells headed your way for those fucking please.
I'm all over them.
Wait,
you had one pooed which is how much?
How much?
That way it's 35 pounds.
So then I got the 1.5 pooed which has probably 50 pounds.
Yeah.
And then it says under there it says 36 pounds.
54 pounds and 72 pounds.
You're telling me I can get all three at the low price of a on the house
had to low price.
If I'm friends with Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
you can get these.
These are bad ass dude.
We had a,
this Guy Steven Shubin Jr.
He's the artist who created these fucking things.
Look at the face on that.
There's no,
Jim is complete without,
without those things.
Decker will is so bad ass fucking face.
Come on.
The guy.
The artist is amazing.
He does like special effects for movies and stuff like that is an artist that is
really hard to do and steel.
I mean I think,
yeah.
Oh Dude.
Well,
you started off in clay and then they just make a mold of it.
But the mold,
it came out like beyond our expectations for the side view.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's a real piece of art.
It's not just a uh,
a workout functional workout equipment too.
It's a real piece of function and workout equipment because we made sure they
were all balanced.
One of the things about kettlebells is part of the exercising with them is
swinging and catching them and you,
you want a very predictable movement.
Meaning you want them sort of centered with their weight,
you know,
so that when you swing it and catch it,
there's no imbalance in the in the curve.
And we worked hard to make sure that these primal kettle bells are completely
balanced.
They're not wacky in any way.
They're really like,
you use them once you realize where the face is,
it's just like using a regular kettle,
but right.
I mean you just,
you just adjust so that the face doesn't bang in your arm.
That's the only,
if they were the most imbalanced things in the world,
I'd still have them in my chat up cause they're so awesome.
So I don't really care.
Yeah.
They're very bad ass and kettle bells like you see this is some fucking very
much omad to strong guy and lifting those things.
It's not a weak guy.
Yeah.
It's a fun exercise man.
And I always tell people like if you're looking for something that absolutely
can enhance your functional strength,
that's the shit.
While we're going to try to talk a little bit about,
yeah,
Mark Epstein,
we're going to talk about,
yeah,
uh,
the guy who wrote the sports gene,
what's possible and what's not possible for white people
was literally what the book was.
Yeah,
that's exactly what we're talking about.
Um,
go to on it.com and uh,
as well as 10% off any and all supplements if you use the code named Rogan.
Uh,
we have all kinds of cool shit there between hemp force protein powder and
buffalo bars and bulletproof coffee and MCT oil.
We sell just the best shit that we can find.
We settled it on it.
I use it.
Use a codeword Rogan,
save yourself some money.
Brian Calendars here.
Hit Jamie it
experience.
Oh it's delicious and nutritious.
Bulletproof coffee and my friend Bryan County,
that's
the new song.
I like that.
And my friend Brian [inaudible],
the podcast is well can we had to make a,
this is Bryan Kaltenbach has this fighter and the kid podcasts and fighter and
the kid kids stop.
You don't stop.
I'll tell you why you don't,
well I get to do it with Brennan shops so I love his take on fighting and then
mine and he gets so mad at me cause I just basically do all my research and ask
everybody about the fights.
Brendan is a bad motherfucker dude.
That that submission that he hit mitre owned with.
It was beautiful.
But cars,
chokers,
he does.
He does.
He did eight pull ups the other day with 125 pounds hanging from his waist.
A strict pull ups,
not kipping.
I believe it.
He's a serious grappler.
That guy can,
he is strong and shit.
You know,
he took a lot of heat for that.
A Gracie a match that metamorris match cause he basically just didn't engage for
awhile.
But there were many moments in the fight where they were engaged.
There was many moments where that Cyborg guy had him in his guard and he's a
dangerous mother fucker Cyborg and Brendan defended every single one of them
sticking his hand in his throat and just stop in that.
That stopped it.
Everything perfect.
But that's a tricky game.
You're playing with that guy.
You're like,
people don't respect that.
Like that Cyborg dude is a nasty motherfucker when it comes to Jujitsu,
his Jujitsu,
it's really,
really,
really high level.
If there's anybody who's earned the nickname Cyborg,
just by the way they look,
it's him.
Yeah.
He felt immediately bad about my genetic structure,
about my fucking bone structure.
Well,
this is a few cyborgs where people who don't know what we're talking about,
this is the upper,
there's a problem.
There's a bunch of cyborgs in Brazil.
Okay.
There's Cris Cyborg Santos,
who was one of the best women fighters in the world.
Really Nasty Moy fighter.
There's
her,
her husband was Ciba evangelists to a Cyborg and then there was this guy,
Roberto I brew,
right.
Is that,
I say his last name,
I believe.
He said,
Bro,
Goddamn,
he's nasty.
He's got a crazy guard.
He goes under guys and then rips their legs apart.
Like ain't as bad as a take down her Steve.
He's a tank is a tank of a human.
Yeah,
and look,
Brendan didn't,
he did a lot of just keeping this guy off of him.
It did a lot of that.
But there were many moments where he was in that guy's guard.
He said,
I think it was the eight times at Eight,
seven,
seven times went down.
Okay.
That's kind of,
that's the fact that he was able to do that.
It's very impressive.
You're just grappling.
Look,
if they were striking,
Brendan would probably,
there's so many positions you would get caught in cause you're smashing.
You guys are hitting him with a punch.
Cyber wouldn't get out of the first round and he would know that.
Well not only that,
there,
that whole position changes entirely like the guard.
Everybody looks at the Guardian,
MMA and the garden MMA,
it's one thing because guys aren't hitting you or guys are hitting you.
Rather when you're in straight Jujitsu,
the guard becomes infinitely more dangerous because you're not going to hit that
guy in the bottom.
So he can grab a hold of you.
He can do things,
he can be wide open and still control you.
As soon as you add punches,
it changes 90% of the Jujitsu cause that's when you,
you're getting you in the face and now you see a lot of guys,
very few guys now will close their legs in MMA because you're taking away two of
your weapons.
You know,
back in the day,
you know,
you,
you the guys,
a lot of guys will try to stand up immediately and stuff like that.
It's a,
it's a very,
very precarious position to be and really depends on your style.
You know,
there's still glass,
the attack,
uh,
off of their back in a full guard like Vinny Magallanes.
I look what happened.
Look what liquid pedis did.
Yes,
that was a beautiful move,
man.
Perfect old school,
Brazilian Jujitsu.
It's still relevant still.
Absolutely.
There's openings.
Just like a right hook is relevant.
The idea,
it goes away.
It's crazy.
They're all,
they're,
all those techniques are there.
When you've got Jake shields,
Damien Maia,
what's your,
what's your calling?
I have a point of view.
Well,
I'll tell you what man.
Damien Maia is a mother fucker at one 70 thank you.
Look what he did to John Fitch.
What worries me about Jake going down to one 70 is a,
Jake looks unhealthy when he does it.
I mean,
maybe he's got that back in order,
but I've seen him in the weigh ins where I'm like,
Geez,
he walks a two o or something.
I mean,
I'm sure he said he's a big fella.
You know,
he's very strong grappler,
but a one 85 he beat some dangerous guys.
Man.
He put,
he put Robbie Lawler,
he tapped him.
He fought a five round fight with Dan Henderson.
That was one of the greatest comebacks in the history of Dan Anderson's Calila
strong from an institution.
Dan Henderson tagged him in that first round.
I mean tagged him like there's not a whole lot of humans that could have
survived that.
He got hit the first round.
Jake Shield showed like the rarest of rare Chin's because Henderson connected
flush on the Chin and he got out of that and started taking Henderson down.
I think Henderson like went into that fight with something wrong with them.
Someone told me that he,
uh,
he had,
back issues.
So it could have been,
I mean,
and I'm not trying to make any excuses for Dan.
I'm sure he wouldn't have made any either.
But a lot of times when you've seen a guy in a fight like that,
like that's what you're dealing with.
You're dealing with a guy goes in there and he's got something wrong,
you know,
and,
and sometimes they throw strategy out the window and just go after a guy you got
to your happy place.
You know,
sometimes you know,
you've got to play it safe.
You know what,
Damien Maia,
when I drink,
when I saw Damien Maia,
what you're talking about with Jake shields,
when I saw it,
Damien Maia control,
uh,
John Fitch for that long and get his back and just basically ride him like that.
You know,
I think that Damien Maia is striking from what I understand is really grown
leaps and bounds and he's,
he's,
he can keep the fight on his feet and a lot of people say that he's,
if he does that with Jake,
he's going to tag Jake up.
But then if he goes to the ground,
there's nothing that suggests that Jake is going to be able to like,
I think his take down rate,
Damien Maia as a wrestler is like 90% or something like he's really effective on
takedowns as well.
So it's going to be,
he's a very special grappler,
is a very special grappler.
His,
his area of improvement is all been his striking catching up to the point where
he could use his grappling more effective effectively.
Like the Rick story fight was even more impressive than the Fitch fight to me.
Cause Rick story is fucking gorilla strong.
That kid is stupid strong.
And Maya got ahold of him and never let go.
I mean it was crazy.
It was the way he did it.
He just is so relentless chasing them down,
holding singles,
tripping them all.
He's holding a single,
dragging them to the mat,
drag up to the mat,
dragged them to the mat,
dragged them to that.
Then finally he's got his back.
Yeah.
And then once he's got you back Das,
when you got your back and you know what they do,
you know what they're finding.
And this leads this book,
uh,
called the sports gene I'm obsessed with right now.
I'm in a lot of people.
He's a sports illustrated,
right?
I think Mark Epstein or David Epstein,
I'm a science writer and they,
they,
well,
why,
why is it that say,
you know what,
what they were trying to figure out why a chess master,
uh,
first of all,
what they found is anybody who's going to be really good at chess,
at grand master or a great athlete,
you can almost always tell by the time they're 12 years old.
And there are a few outliers,
but just by the way they behave and the way they work and stuff like that,
and it's not,
the 10,000 hour rule actually is a very shotty rule because some people can take
four out thousand hours,
other people can take,
you know,
25,000 hours.
It all depends.
But um,
one of the things that they found about people who master something like great
wrestlers,
great judo guys,
great boxers like Floyd Mayweather is,
isn't even so much that they are faster or stronger experience.
You have to have a certain hardware,
what they call a hardware,
like a genetic hardware.
You've got to be,
you know,
but experience when you look at Damien Maia,
when he,
when he rolls experience allows the human mind to be able to chunk information.
You can,
he's able to chunk shit in larger quantity.
So what he's
doing is he's reading signals s way before he's reading signals that you're
giving him even tendencies and he's able to make assumptions.
Even if he's not aware of it,
he's may able to jump three moves ahead because he's making an assumption.
He's already predicting what you're going to do.
You're thinking about it,
and he can tell by the way,
you're shifting your weight from years of experience.
Oh,
I've been here before and he compensates much faster than you do and that's the
difference when when,
oh,
whoa,
that's a mind blower.
It's a mindblower.
When when they have these recognize your patterns before people make specific,
he's memorized the board.
He's memorized every conceivable position on that chess board.
As a Jujitsu player,
that's exactly what great chess masters are able to do.
They can show a great chess master,
obscure games with obscure things for three seconds and then they can read.
They can tell you what exactly,
what the where everything was.
It's really terrifying when you're rolling with a guy who's really,
really fucking good because one of the things is you feel the progressions.
You feel like you're lucky.
You're trapped in his full guard.
Oh Shit.
And I was got my arm.
Now he's locked in the shoulder.
Oh Shit.
Now it's tighter.
Oh Shit,
now I'm in trouble.
I'm in fucking real trouble.
It's like there's a real progression.
It's not like a wild scramble where you know someone catches a gay teen.
It's a real,
you are dictating to an extent whether you know it or not,
what he's going to do next in the sense that when he,
when he moves,
you have a compensation as you compensate,
he's already ahead of you.
He's pulling,
never understand that if they've never played chess or if they've never done
Jujitsu angst or whatever,
but the box is,
I think there's less dimensions to it just because the fact that it's just
hands,
but then clearly you see a guy like Floyd Mayweather who can keep boxing against
the best guys in the world and barely get hit and the reason is exactly what
they were saying is that phlegm in where she's still,
when you box,
you'd learn all the different patterns,
right?
There are different patterns that you learned footwork here that what he's able
to do is he knows that if he will,
based on this pattern,
he learned how,
okay you,
you create this opening,
then you step to the side and you do this.
What he'll do is jump to to pattern three.
He'll literally anticipate,
he can see that you're moving over here and he's so far ahead of you and that's
why it's impossible to touch the guy he's seeing before you throw the punch what
based on your body language and based on where your eyes are,
he's able to chunk all that information so quickly that he is,
the minute you think about it,
the second you think,
oh,
I'm going to do this.
He's already headed.
He goes,
oh,
he's going to do this and now his hands up before.
Well that's sort of interesting because it's,
it's hard to explain.
It's sparring I think to someone who's never spartan before and to a lot of
folks when you look at it,
it looks like one guy is trying to hit the God.
The other guy was trying to hit the guy and they kind of meet in the middle and
figure out who hits who when.
There's a lot of weirdness to sparring.
There's a rhythm to it is,
it's a very strange thing.
Getting him to think something and then capitalizing on,
you know,
getting used to being hit too.
There's that.
You have to be able to keep your,
your,
your shit about you while things are flying at your face.
Some people just,
they see things fly at their faces.
Well your heart,
your head goes down and it takes a long time.
I've worked at instinct out of your body,
being able to look,
eat,
see a punch into your face basically.
We'll do it a lot of,
unfortunately a lot of people's instincts is definitely look for the punch.
It's tried to like to have their heads straight up in the air.
It's like what's going on?
Try and see things more clearly so they're sticking their neck up and getting
cracked.
That happens in a panic mode.
You see a lot of guys in a panic mode,
like they'll drop their hands down.
I'll never forget.
Um,
there was a fight in front of the comedy store one night and I don't know who
started what.
I have no idea what was going on.
All I just knew it was that these two guys were in this really heated exchange
and one guy was a white guy and one guy was a black guy and uh,
the white guy went into full slap panic standing square and it just literally
doing this,
it was so crazy.
It was so crazy.
He was just,
he had a full meltdown.
First of all,
I couldn't believe that he was about to have a fist fight with this guy who
clearly look more physically strong,
much larger.
Looked like a,
like an athlete,
you know?
And so I don't know what happens.
I saw the slapping and the freaking and then a bus drove in front of,
or no,
and I couldn't see anything for like,
you know,
15 seconds or whatever it was until the bus was gone and then boom,
the white guys down flat.
So some in between him flailing,
he got caught,
he got,
he got smashed.
He was completely unconscious on the concrete in the street at all.
You have to do is get in a ring.
Just chuck playing around with a guy who can actually,
I always say that people like if you think you're talking about getting a ring
with any cruiserweight who's even an amateur,
I been boxing a long time.
You won't touch him and he'll hit you once in your whole life will change.
You'll be like,
I don't want to ever do this again,
and guys that are really good with footwork,
they always make you feel so stupid because if you're a person who's never,
you're going to move off balance.
This guy is going to be moving on and you're going to be like,
oh,
you're not even there.
Like,
oh Jesus.
Like you know,
it's a language that they had an amazing spirit experiment in this book where
Major League baseball players,
almost all of them are off the charts visually.
They have 2010 2017 visuals.
There's almost no really great hitters there.
I don't think there are any who have even 2020 vision.
They almost all without a doubt have vision that is off the charts there in the
one percentile.
I'm talking about all major league hitters.
Uh,
and,
and the book is very eloquent and about this.
And so they took Albert Poo hosts and who and Alex Rodriguez and some incredible
hitters,
like the best of all time of their generation.
And they had um,
and one of the things they found is that when a baseball,
it comes at you at 95 miles an hour from 60 feet away,
you have to guess where it's going.
You're
not going to see it.
The human eye cannot register in time to actually see and hit the ball.
So what great hitters do is they're able to actually see the seams on the ball.
They're able to see the seams on the ball and through years and years of how
those scenes are rolling and how that pitcher throws the ball,
they're able,
if they're very good,
30% of the time they are able to predict and start swinging basically when he
lets go of the ball.
So that's where why curve balls and shit work.
Yes,
they can change where the ball's going to be changed direction.
But also the way you hit a curve off you're really great is you have,
you can see the way these guys can literally cause they have such good eyes can
see the pattern of the red strings coming at you at 95 miles an hour.
They can chunk all that information quickly enough and start swinging low as
opposed to hi and connect to you have to guess now they take the greatest
hitters in major league baseball and they take out female Olympic softball
pitcher who pitches underhand.
Now the distance is about 40 feet,
a little bit more than 40 feet.
The ball's coming over at about 60 miles an hour,
not 95 miles an hour and she pitches underhand.
Now these are the best pitchers and they hit a much smaller ball at 95 miles an
hour.
She struck out every single picture over and over and over again because guess
what?
There are novices cause you know why they couldn't guess.
They were looking at a very different ball.
They didn't have the strings and she was pitching underhand so they,
there was no way for them to predict anything.
They were swinging blind and they were as bad as you and I.
How about that?
That's amazing.
Yeah.
So the more you learn,
the more we learn.
Not only about you have to have a certain hardware.
We know as an athlete you are never going to be,
you and I are never going to be sprinters.
It ain't happening.
Sorry.
Shit.
You don't come from west Africa.
It was never very fast runner.
There were European dude short legs.
It's not going to happen.
You have much longer legs than me though.
Not really.
I got the long torso.
It's very unfortunate and mess.
I'm a mess.
This why?
Why we go to Montana.
I got seven layers on a can't stay warm and you're all toasty cause you're but
like an Inuit.
I'm built like a fucking tulip.
Why I just dressed right and cashmere.
That's true too.
Cause I have Hama a very classic cashmere.
I was three layers.
I was worried.
Real hunting gear.
I was wearing Ryan Callahan.
I brought three expensive layers of cashmere wool.
It's all about wool,
wolves,
wolves.
Amazing.
Yeah.
Was amazing.
It's amazing that in this day and age,
like that's the best shit as well.
Like a wool blend.
No Shit.
Even after all these years,
if it gets wet,
you want to be in wool,
they say cotton kills,
right?
Yes it does.
Yeah.
You can get sweaty in the cotton and it sticks to you and cools your body down
to the point where it gets dangerous.
You can get hypothermia.
It's just like being wet and it's not like you're going to take the clothes off,
you know,
you're f you're outside frozen so you're fucked.
No thanks.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't want to die that way.
We'll is what's up wools.
Amazing.
And,
and they've,
and they also,
in this book,
they also talk about the idea rod in different cultures of how,
like when you're
closer to the equator,
you want longer limbs.
Why?
Because it's a larger area of space for you to get rid of heat.
So,
so if you look at,
um,
for the most part,
people from Africa who,
Kenya for example,
they have a very different structure.
Their bodies are structured differently than I was a born in a much higher
altitude.
You're not beating a Kenyan in a long distance rate.
Grace,
it ain't happening.
Don't they run down animals until they die?
Persistence.
And that certainly was the,
if you read,
born to run,
that's certainly what what our ancestors did.
And that's why human beings are the best long distance runners of any animal,
period.
We are,
we can run longer than any animal,
any antelope,
any horse.
We can run for a day.
If you train for it and no animal can do that.
Tell me this,
why don't cowboys ride people?
Ah,
I shit you going to ask me a question?
Ride horses and horses and walk all day.
I don't get it.
You and your parables.
Fucking stupid bullshit.
Sensei Joe.
Fuck it.
A person have worn Dorrance in a horse.
That might be one of the dumbest things I've ever heard in my life.
What happens when you have me as a guest?
I can't buy that in any way.
Straight through for people ride bucking horses,
man.
Not only can a person ride a horse all day,
but they're on the horse.
The horse is running with a person on them.
Well that's true.
Saddle if you're a fucking real man,
if you traveled with rifles like Clint Eastwood in life,
we're given and my trench coat,
I can't buy that sun and less.
No,
it's actually a fact.
It's actually a fact that human beings have the best long distance runners of
any animal park.
It'd be better than a horse because a horse actually cannot run after.
If you had a horse run for 26 miles,
you can have a horse walk.
If you had a horse run for 26 miles or 30 miles or whatever,
it would start to break down.
Yes.
And it will not do that well.
It would even get a tail.
Even a wild horse.
They never run long distances ever.
So they're just running away from Cheetahs.
Yes,
they run stop cheetahs.
Cheetahs like in a wild horse.
Cause we have a lot of,
you know why you can never domesticate a zebra.
They've tried a thousand times.
Their dicks are two big nope.
That's good question.
Good.
Good answer.
Good answer sir.
But you're wrong.
Do you know why?
Why they cannot they?
Because a zebra will bite you.
That's one thing.
Horses will bite you.
Wild horses.
It bites you.
It gets what is Ebro do.
Hold on.
And it won't let go.
Oh God.
Oh yeah.
No Zebra hold on you and start twisting it.
So that's it.
Oh my God.
So by two clamps onto like a pit bull,
whether it's super long,
gigantic,
powerful jaw.
Yup.
You are never domesticating a cheetah.
I mean a,
um,
uh,
never domesticating a zebra.
You're never riding a zebra and they've tried even crossbreeding it with other
animals ain't happening.
They fucking hate you.
They're nasty striped motherfuckers.
Yeah,
I would imagine they would be Kentucky.
They have to be,
you're out there living with fucking crocodiles to left you and lines to the
right.
Sucks.
Life is a zebra.
That's gotta be the worst life.
And you can't afford an ACL tear cause you don't have a year.
That's,
we can say that.
I was in Colorado recently and I saw a deer with a broken leg.
It was so sad.
It was a dealer,
a female deer with a mouthwatering.
When you say that and then keep going because you got high before.
I know I just love venison.
But yeah,
the uh,
the poor dears bone was actually sticking out the bottom of its leg and it just
made me think like instantly about medical care and about it,
you know,
being a human and how much we take for granted,
the ability to repair ourselves and the ability that doctors have,
you know,
the,
the ability that they have today of fixing so many ailments with the human body.
When I went to Springfield,
I went to the Lincoln Museum.
Lincoln lost three of his children,
but a tad at for Willie at 11.
And in his other son at 17 on both to typhus,
fever.
And I thought to myself,
the present United States lost three of his kids to disease back then.
That was so commonplace.
And he had one child left by the time he died.
I believe in and think about you and I have kids.
Think about the misery of a four year old losing a four year old,
11 year old.
We can't imagine it.
That was the norm back then.
Bearing a child,
why didn't have vaccines,
didn't have antibiotics,
didn't have anesthesia,
it didn't have medical care the way we do now and didn't even know really what
pathogens were.
So when dip theory and typhus fever and things like that rolled through,
you know,
this is why I get so mad at the anti vaccine movement.
Pick up a history book,
pick up a history book and see what happened before we had that kind of
healthcare.
We owe a great deal to people like you on a sock and the inventors of things
like the smallpox vaccine,
those are horrible.
Not just diseases but also surgery.
What,
what they're able to do today.
I mean there's the first ever FDA approved bionic eye is ready for commercial
launch in the U s yeah.
Pull that up on my,
uh,
wow.
Pulled it up on my,
it's on my Twitter feed.
I put it on there this morning.
It's on Cnet,
dude.
We are bashing with machines now.
There's a little commercial that plays before,
but it's incredible.
They're,
uh,
they've been working on this bionic eye and,
the first ever FDA approved bionic,
I will soon be launching commercially in the United States device device.
Could help tens of thousands of people suffer from a rare degenerative eye
disease.
So is it an actual eyeball or something or,
I don't know.
Oh my God.
But it's allowing people to see,
I think it's something you wear like glasses.
It attaches to the optic nerve or something.
Whoa.
This is crazy.
Oh my God.
This is some Super Cyborg Shit.
Let me see.
Yeah.
This guy was a blind guy.
Now he's moving around.
This is insane.
He,
uh,
he's got these glasses on and he,
he's uh,
doing all kinds of different shit.
This is really kind of naughty.
Let's hear this.
Tony Dean Lloyd suffers from retinitis Pigmentosa,
a degenerative eye disease,
which destroys photo receptors,
cells,
and impedes a person's ability to detect light.
I saw nothing I slept.
Maybe I could ascertain daytime from nighttime.
That was the only thing I could be say for 17 years.
Now.
A device at 20 years in the making that will soon be commercially available in
the US is helping patients like Lloyd I perception was sort of like a flash of
light or a star that you might see in the sky.
Well,
no,
I can see boundaries and borders.
The artists to buy second site was FDA approved earlier this year and patients
are being screened at the 12 major US hospitals chosen as implant centers and
you can hear it beeping away.
The device includes a chip with an array of electrodes that's implanted on the
retina and glasses with a video camera that wirelessly transmits images.
It converts that video into a 60 pixel image that then delivers electronic
impulses to the 60 little electrodes in the chip that then stimulate the retina
to generate,
uh,
perception.
Our message that the brain can then interpret and understand.
They're just not credible.
It doesn't restore vision,
but patients can detect light and dark.
Thus identifying an object location and movement or walk down the sidewalk.
My bus stop to my office on a daily basis and I can see where the grass comes up
til I sidewalk this like concrete color.
The device is not going to enable them to drive a car or you know,
read fine print on a newspaper,
but that it might help them enjoy a better quality of life.
Some patients report that they can see the outline,
but it's a start.
It's a start.
Yeah.
And a,
I know they have,
um,
they have implants now too for certain,
uh,
certain things that go wrong with people's eyes.
Like someone was talking about their,
their grandmother.
Was it Kathleen Madigan was talking about her grandmother driving all of her
friends around because she had her eyes fixed.
Oh yeah,
you told me about that.
Yeah,
I remember that.
I'm not sure if it was Kathleen,
um,
whoever it was,
you know,
we're getting close to,
I just can't,
as I'm reading this book,
this portion,
and I'm like,
when are they going to come up with gene doping where I can,
my whole body can be ridiculously fast.
Twitch.
I think you're going to be able to be a zebra one day.
Well,
that's big.
It's going to be that crutch.
Craig venter says,
right?
You're going to have a brain inside of zebras body.
You could,
you could do whatever the fuck you want.
Check this out.
This is what I blew my mind about,
about this.
So,
so if you take a huge guy like,
uh,
I Allister over rain or you know,
Brendan Shop,
do you know how much more his skeleton ways than say mine?
Um,
I'm 170 pound guy,
but I probably a lot more,
yeah,
of course.
6.5 pounds more maybe.
Really?
Yes.
In that crazy.
Yeah,
because you have to look at it as a book bookshelf.
Some people have a wider bookshelf,
but actually the bones themselves are our six,
you know,
they're a little bit wider.
The structure of your skeletons,
a little bit like inches,
like inches,
like say three,
three inches in leg bone is a lot.
Right?
So now you're 65 or whatever.
Right.
But um,
that,
that
actual scaffolding allows you to put on.
Um,
I think,
uh,
I can't remember what the ratio is,
but like 1.1 pounds of muscle can support 11 pounds of bone can support 11
pounds of muscle.
So you,
so just kind of like,
no,
but this is in the book,
but I was amazed at that.
Like a huge guy.
Only his bone structure is only 6.5 pounds heavier.
I wouldn't get,
he's an NFL Lineman,
one of us,
like much,
much heavier.
No,
the rest is bones and,
and the rest is muscle and tendon tissue.
It's quite some money.
Well that's a lot of fucking weight and muscle and tendon smashing you down with
the extra 60 pounds.
Yeah,
yeah,
it is.
It's weird though that it's only six pounds.
I was amazed at that.
I'm a wealth of information,
ladies and gentlemen,
I would have assumed it was way more than that.
I would have assumed it was like 50 or something crazy.
You know,
I'm getting him on my podcast.
I'm excited.
Well,
human body weight is a fascinating thing to me because I watch all these guys
cut weight for fighting and it's just really shocking.
What's,
what's possible like water,
right?
How much water you lose.
Different guys do it a different way.
Some guys lose,
uh,
all their body fat first and then they dehydrate,
you know,
the discipline that it takes to get to like your optimum weight.
Like Damien Maia is finally at one 70 for a long time.
He fought at one 85 and he just couldn't overpower these guys like that.
You know,
he's dealing with a lot of guys that were like really physically strong.
Like to Anderson Anderson's very physically strong.
So even if he could get ahold of Anderson that fight,
which he really had a hard to have you or you've talked to a fighters to talk
about strong.
He is.
He's very physically strong and beans.
Yes.
Anderson's very physically strong.
You can tell in the,
uh,
the rich Franklin fights when Anderson locks a hold of him with the Thai camp.
It's a nasty Thai clinch.
I mean it's really good and rich,
rich Franklin is a very strong guy and rich Franklin up until that fight,
it never really been dominated in a fight.
He had some good fights,
some,
some wins and some losses.
He fought well,
you know,
all throughout his career.
But that was the first fight where it looked like he really just,
he was on another level,
the guy who was fighting just done a completely different league.
And a big part of that was Anderson controlling him and the Thai clinch
controlling him and just,
and then with knees,
his,
his Thai clinch,
his death.
Yeah.
That's a strong guy.
Plus he has one,
you know,
you don't get to have that kind of one punch knockout power,
and be able to submit guys with triangles as well,
unless you have some physical.
How tall is Anderson?
Uh,
would you say?
Really?
Six.
Two.
He's 60,
not six.
Three,
maybe six to whatever it says.
How much shorter is he than Jon Jones?
Jon is not just taller.
John's just much bigger.
You know,
even if it's a two inch thing,
that two inches.
This is a million miles.
Yeah.
John is a big dude with those long arms.
John's a master at a distance.
How about using the opposite?
Like it's,
so if you're a smaller guy and you're dealing with a guy like John,
he's gonna fuck you up at a distance that you can't touch him.
I mean he's the master at that.
If you watch his fight with Rashad Evans,
you watch his fight with Quintin Jackson.
He's the master at keeping guys and the end of his shots like,
and they come at him.
Nope.
On the shoulders,
pushes him off,
kick to the leg,
back to my range,
back to the range where only he can hit you.
Right.
So he's like sniping at you and then when you come out of him he just controls
you.
And then on top of that he's got the great wrestling.
So it's like if you actually do clinch up with them,
guess what?
He's ridiculously physically strong,
very technical,
and he's a really good fucking wrestler.
He's got some real skills.
Plus we'll do wild shit.
You know,
he,
he'll like,
he'll throw dude.
So launch dudes for the hair.
Like people forget about that.
He hasn't been doing that,
you know?
I mean,
John was like smashing guys in the beginning of his career.
Like if you look the [inaudible] fight,
like the first fight where Gustava Dante is when he was in the UFC,
he launched that dude.
I mean,
launched him.
Yeah.
It was like,
it was crazy to why stronger than people think it's not the right name.
Yeah,
no,
he's very strong.
He's very strong.
You know?
Man,
that last fight was incredible.
Him and Gustafson,
I was one of the most amazing fights,
I think the most amazing fight I've ever seen.
And that's saying a lot because you've seen thousand fights.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure it was.
I mean,
it's,
it's hard to say like what's the most amazing,
but it's certainly in right?
Shocking,
right?
I mean,
yeah.
Yeah,
it's right up there.
Uh,
I wonder how they're,
how they're going to adjust their training for this next fight.
You know,
uh,
that's a good question.
I know that I,
I'm really looking forward to the junior dos Santos,
uh,
Cain Velasquez fight because John Gray goose mouth.
That's who it was.
It wasn't Gustavo Dante is cause it's Tom looked down to as a,
as a Jujitsu guy.
My,
my apologist,
it was Andre Goose Mallee farm.
That was when he first started launching people through the air spinning elbows.
And it's just a few years ago,
man,
which is really weird.
That was the 2008 credit seems like last missing,
it seems like three months.
Amazing.
And I'll tell you what,
man,
I've seen him in some tough fights.
I've seen him in some really good fights.
I've never seen anybody get that close to him as as Gustafson did.
Well,
the one thing I was when they lined up and you and I were right there cage side,
the one thing I noticed was that he would,
that goes Gustafson.
It's taller.
John is an inch taller.
I was like,
what are you talking about?
Yeah.
He's a big dude,
dude.
That kind of got a lot better.
He got a little better.
3.5% of Americans are,
I think it's that are our six three are over in that crazy.
There's um,
an inside the UFC thing they're doing about Gustafson when they showed him
training a up for the fight and the attitude that this guy has,
this guy's like,
he's straight viking,
straight up fucking,
it's all stoic is straight Vikki DNA.
One of the things that he said,
he said,
I'm never satisfied.
He goes,
the life of a,
an elite athlete is you're never satisfied.
You can never be happy with what you did because then you're going to get fucked
up.
You know?
It was like,
that was his attitude every day,
no matter how dominant he is.
Like,
and that,
that was like how he seemed like after his fight,
like after his fight it was like,
you know,
hey,
it was what it was.
And you know,
John's a good fighter and that's it.
That's how me,
he let it go on moving on.
But he,
I think he realizes that this is the part of a trilogy that you know,
no time to relax.
Well I wish they would just get right after it.
I mean I,
I,
I'm torn because I really want to see Glover versus John.
I think that's a really interesting fight and Glover is a fucking killer.
He's a killer.
That guy's dangerous.
Glover is very,
very,
very highly on the wrestling team too.
He's a wrestler as well as did you described,
could have easily been a world champion by now and in any other way class with
any other set of circumstances.
If he had been in the UFC earlier and had a chance to fight against higher
levels of competition just six,
seven years ago,
he could have been a champion.
That's no bullshit.
That's legit.
He had a v a big time visa issue.
But if you look at like the,
the highest level guys who knows who's going to win when they get in there,
but you all know who the top guys are.
And on any given night in a lot of search circumstances,
like the hundred 70 pound division,
George dominates that division,
right?
Georgia has been beating everybody,
but the reality is he's surrounded by a bunch of murderers everywhere he turns,
and at any given day,
one of those guys could get them.
Carlos condit almost got him.
He had kicked him and dropped him.
Matt Serra got him.
He was the only guy to ever really get them like that.
Matt,
Matt Hughes got him,
caught him in an arm bar back early in his career.
Yeah.
But when you look at like the amount of murderers in his division,
it makes you realize how good he is.
I mean,
Carlos condit is as good as it gets.
Even better now.
I know it's even better now.
He's even better now.
He got that loss,
made him take it to the next level.
He's,
he's,
he's just phenomenal.
That's his fucking last fight.
So good.
Martin Kampmann.
He's a beautiful man.
I mean,
I was,
I watched,
I watched this fight with Gis.
I was rooting for DSG.
I Love des because Nick Diaz is my hero.
I just love his attitude and,
and every single girl that is watching Carlos Condit faluting mine is literally
go wide.
And,
and I,
I,
I literally,
I felt bad about myself and jealous and I was,
I could have been rooting for content more.
And then I watched them just keep turning that corner.
I was like,
you got to give it to this guy.
He's like a bonafide new Mexican cowboy.
He sure has.
Man Wash Stud.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He's getting better.
For sure.
Genetically he's got much longer legs than I do,
sir.
Oh,
he's very tall.
He's very tall and he knows how to use it and he's,
he's,
one of the things that he has it a lot of people don't talk about is his
fitness.
His fitness level is like very elite.
The pace that he could keep in a fight.
It's one of the things that he,
you know,
one of the things that always worked with Nick Diaz,
his,
his ability to outpace guys.
So it's,
there's times in a fight and it's,
if you've never fought before,
it's hard to imagine.
But there's times in a fight where one guy is coasting or were you sort of
almost agree to coast or where you know everybody relaxes the aggression a
little bit.
Like in a tough fight.
25 minute fight happens and yeah,
because you don't go 100% you have to pace yourself.
Well Nick Diaz can go just a little
bit faster,
a little bit longer and he can go round after round of dry.
He could do 30 minutes of MMA.
It's called doing triathlons.
Exactly.
It's called long training or overtraining.
His masonic overtrading caught long training.
His endurance is insane.
I mean it's insane.
So he would just get on guys like a guy like Paul daily.
Just get on him and stay on it.
Yeah,
just go after him.
Talk Shit.
Boxers.
The coaches would have you run for an hour and a half slowly.
Not Long.
They keep your heart rate up at a certain level.
It's kind of like triathlon training.
Back in the day as a boxer,
they would make you,
if you're running a fighting,
a 15 round fight,
good luck.
They would make you literally run for an hour and a half to two hours and it
wouldn't be long running.
I wouldn't be hard running but it would be running.
And what,
they never really found a substitute for that particular kind of training for
it,
for fighting because it puts you into a cardiovascular state,
uh,
where where you will,
you will be able to sustain for set for a long time and man,
just having been arrested or six minutes is,
is an Aeon nine minutes in college freestyle is a nightmare.
Um,
I can't imagine 15,
I can't imagine 25 minutes.
When you're mixing and punching,
it's,
it's truly,
you truly have to be,
you know,
a,
a freak and,
and even being able to your vo Max being some people just either have it or
don't.
That's another genetic thing where you can either use oxygen more efficiently
when you're boxing,
wrestling,
cycling,
running.
Some people just convert auction in a much more efficient manner into their red
blood cells.
Then do other people.
So your vo Max can be worked on for sure.
And you can,
you can increase your cardiovascular risk.
But some people just have a jump on it,
you know,
like depending on what your genetic makeup,
when you know,
there's a really funny bill burb bit were Bill Berwin on Conan O'brien and it
was talking about Lance Armstrong loved it.
I loved it.
Pull that shit up.
Pull that shit up with play that,
cause it's hilarious because it's so fucking true.
Bill burr on Kona talking about Lance Armstrong.
It's genius.
It's not sociopath like yeah,
well it's his,
his take on it is so dead on.
Like they're all on drugs.
Everybody was on drugs like my friend and your friend,
you know the guy.
We won't,
we don't have to say his name.
Uh,
who was,
uh,
it was a pro cycler at one point in time.
He knew about this.
He's always said this like way back in the day.
He was like,
look,
they're all on trucks.
Cause I was on it.
Everybody in the team was on it.
He goes,
you would hear guys get off the bus in the middle of the night and unrack their
bike cause they had to go running because their EPO was making them fucking
crazy.
God,
yeah,
whatever it does,
it makes your heartbeat funny and you start feeling weird and you're,
you're,
you're basically gumming up your fucking,
you gotta you gotta blow out some,
some blood.
Yeah,
that's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
And,
and my,
my problem with with Lance Armstrong was that,
not that he even did drugs,
but that he destroyed other people who accused him of doing drugs and he got
lawsuits and everything else.
Yeah.
He used,
he was a bad influence and money to,
to do harm to the bad guy.
And people who were calling him out on it,
we're calling them out because they wanted everyone to be,
you know.
Well there are also some point in time,
some of them were subpoenaed,
some of them didn't have a choice.
They were brought up on,
you know,
when you're,
when the u s government's going,
you know,
you better tell the truth.
You're going to jail,
you're going to tell the truth.
And this is what the,
you know,
the argument against it or the personal freedom argument I don't think really
works in this one because I think you have to know exactly what's there,
what everyone's doing to find out if it in fact it's safe.
Because when you're dealing with this is an extraordinarily dirty sport,
extraordinarily dirty,
like perhaps 90 plus percent of the top people and 100% of the winners are doing
something.
They're taking blood out of their body,
they're putting it back in their body.
That's super common.
They like to do that one.
They,
uh,
they elect to use EPO,
which does the same thing through a chemical.
They're all on testosterone.
They're the,
and it's actually been argued that it's safer to do the Tour de France.
No.
So I say France.
It was beautiful.
Right?
We're all done.
That's amazing that you just did that.
I never would have expected them to do that.
That's awesome.
The Tour de France would it flows.
Like I said,
no Chaddam one time and said no,
this one doctor was saying that it actually might be safer to do it on the drugs
then to do it off it because it's such a strain on your body when you do it
without the reserves.
So talking about like it's all about your ability to recover from what you're
putting out and how much can you put out and how much can you recover and how
well do you know your body?
What a certain point points time.
These guys were in running a little late thirties and they were covering like he
like young pups,
like 18 year olds.
You ever see an 18 year old get a scratch?
It's gone tomorrow.
They just,
he loved the,
they're like the Wolverine.
Other heal.
Well,
do you remember how your hard,
your Dick was always hard when you were 18 like those levels of hormones are
never reached again.
I never forgot.
One time I was,
I was thinking about this girl.
There's like young lists.
It's like 23.
I was in New York,
I was on my way to theater class and I'm walking down like,
like Alexa,
and I'm just thinking about this.
Yeah,
this girl.
And I start getting a fucking Chubby as I'm walking.
I was wearing these pants and I hear this big,
very gay black man go,
oh,
he got,
he started and he started walking along with me,
looking at packages is handicapped,
will look and go on.
And he was just so into me and I was like,
I gotta get,
I gotta get this thing down right now and I got to get out of here.
It was that he followed me for a block and gay guys would hit on,
and you just like guys will hit on girls.
He got to know everybody who thinks that because someone's gay,
you know,
I've,
I've actually been talking about this on stage that they're automatically going
to be nice.
You're crazy.
Like that's a person.
God Damn Right.
Everybody should get their first,
uh,
you know,
blank slate.
I agree with that.
Gay,
straight,
black,
white,
Asian,
whatever,
whatever.
Who Cares?
He's a complicated human beings.
The rest of it gets real freaky.
Just cause you suck dicks doesn't mean you're awesome.
Fuck No.
Nor does it mean you're,
you're ethical that he won't tackle you with the knees.
Yeah.
There's a lot of weird people out there period.
I'm sure there are guys you know that look at you and go,
you know there are probably,
there are gay rapists,
like they are straight rapists.
I mean it,
it,
all the whole human spectrum exists within whatever you are.
What else?
I mean if there's bad people,
there's bad people in every single walk of life.
It's,
there's all sorts of possible combinations of people,
how they turn out,
but you know that those days,
those hormone days of the 18 like that.
Like I look back on that sometimes and I'm like,
how was I ever expected to make decisions for myself?
Back then I was just raised hormonal mess as was.
Everyone was friends with the greatest,
you have the greatest metaphor I've ever heard in my life.
One of the greatest bits I've ever actually in my life seen anywhere.
To me that the eye,
what it's like for a guy to have a hard on these younger is like you're in the
back of a boss and somebody else is driving that bus and that whole bit you did
to me,
top five greatest spits of all time.
I don't have that on there.
Anything you don't,
oh my God,
you're crazy.
That's a genius.
But that's like that's a bit I got a lazy with and I sort of abandoned.
I would have it and I'd let it go.
I blew my mind.
That was what I was literally like,
it was so inspiring.
I went home and I started writing.
I did it.
It's funny cause that bit was a bit,
that would work really well or there was too many dance moves in it.
That's what Tom Segura calls it.
When you're jazzing up a bit,
whatever,
Dude,
you got your physical.
But that,
that thing,
I don't care how many dance moves you're doing that anybody doesn't think that's
genius.
And by the way,
it may just be that it's so good people that are actually just watching cause I
wasn't even laughing.
Most of that was watching it so fascinated with the metaphor and how you were
doing it that I was just like,
this is the greatest thing I've ever seen him on.
So you know,
I'll put it on some,
I'll put it on the next year.
It's too late.
Come on.
It'll be a baby it to me.
I want to do it on my next special,
which I'm shooting in January.
I think we're going to shoot it.
I think.
I don't know yet,
but I have an offer to do it down in Orange County.
Oh cool.
Yeah.
But uh,
you know,
we'll see.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to do way more comedy clubs then.
That's the greatest.
Yeah,
I'm been,
the last couple of weeks I've been doing,
I did a bunch of the Improv's.
I did Braya Ontario,
I did the comedy Magic Club and doing all these club dates and I'm having so
much fun,
man.
I'm like,
it's really like the shows or the intimacy of the room is something I'm really
like in love with.
Again,
I was in Springfield,
Illinois,
which is,
I'm sorry to everybody from Springfield.
It's not a place you'd go for really anything.
How rude.
No,
it's but,
but the people are great because they all grew up together.
They all know each other since fifth grade,
so it's a really great community.
Fucking great
crowds.
Good luck.
Yes.
Money around town is banging people that fucked up the high school and now
you're married to somebody else,
but you lived down the street.
There's one drink,
walks a log.
What do you doing?
Well,
they don't get,
the problem is they all complain about the fact that you can't get away with
anything because everybody knows you,
so you have to be on your best behavior all the time.
You can't be anonymous,
which was really interesting.
So it's like a small scale model of the future Internet.
That's exactly right.
It's like a giant Facebook,
but he's bagging everybody.
Everybody knows it.
Everybody is watching everything you do.
But I was thinking,
I love going on the road like that because you had these intimate experiences
with a bunch of strangers and,
and because there's not a lot to do.
I'm sitting there writing the whole time.
It's interesting too when you're talking about that,
about this small town and everybody knowing everybody.
You know Dr Chris Ryan who've had on this podcast for the guy who wrote that
book sex at dawn,
when he talks about like promiscuity,
like he talks about promiscuity and primitive cultures,
which is basically fact,
okay.
What they're basing it on is almost the same thing as a small town.
It's everybody knowing everybody there in these small groups,
everybody knows everybody and everybody fucks everybody.
That's right.
And it happens all the time.
He does,
right?
It happens.
It happens all the time.
That's what happens when you get down to a group of 50 people.
And they found that even,
even as crazy as this sounds,
that small groups of people that are involved in dangerous situations,
they turned to wife swapping like fighter pilots.
Wow.
Fighter pilots on a regular basis.
Wife swap,
cop's wife swap.
So really?
Yeah.
Because they love their wife and if they're dead,
they want someone else to love their wife too.
That makes total sense.
And they want to be there while like almost while it's happening,
like you introduce someone to your wife.
She's really special person and like,
like he's like almost like accepted a new reality and that reality is my lights
are going to shut out any second now,
dude,
I'd way rather have you married my wife and raising my kids in anybody else.
I know that feeling.
You know what I'm talking about.
That's that feeling,
that feeling is that says to me,
you would know that I could trust.
You can trust me and you know,
or vice versa.
I can trust you.
That's life man.
That's what people do when they get to small groups,
they bond job and they breed with each other in order to form love bonds at.
So it's more about love than it is about being a freak.
And the weird thing about that word promiscuity is the original origin of the
word means mixed,
mixed sex,
sex with you,
sex with her.
They were fucking each other.
They're having gay sex,
like a lot of people throughout history,
we're having gay sex then that's absolutely fact.
And that's one of the interesting things about luck.
You know,
and I'm just talking here,
I'm not advocating gay sacks,
but what I am saying is damn it,
it's very strange that in groups of of men,
when men were warring and when they were off like fighting and wars and
disappearing together and through the woods for six months,
they were out
banging each other and killing each other.
Yeah.
I mean they were just killing each other.
They were banging each other too.
That was the,
I was the idea behind the Spartans are,
you know,
a lot of cultures that separated men and women for a long time.
There's a great deal of,
you know,
because guys are fucking animals,
right?
So as you see some due to smaller and kind of a feminine,
you're like,
I'm going to fuck that guy today.
You know,
they didn't just do that.
They also formed love bonds because they knew that they were most likely going
to die.
I think when your reality gets radically altered,
like you're in a situation like a fighter pilot is,
or like a,
a person who is perhaps going off to war,
you're dealing with a very real scenario of the end of your life.
It's really funny.
My buddies,
one of the CIA,
paramilitary guys,
a real bad ass and he works with all the special forces guys,
right?
Like the Delta guys and the seal team,
six guys and the seals and they were all up in arms.
He was,
he was in their barracks and one,
one of these groups to this state that what they call a,
a Cag,
a combat action group,
you know,
like break everything.
Cag.
And these guys are like a real bad ass,
like a triple,
triple nickel,
18 whatever,
you know.
And uh,
and they're all like the studs and they were all like complaining about the
don't ask,
don't tell like gays in the military,
father and me.
Well he looked at him,
he was like,
you guys,
you guys have Trojan call names.
Just shave your forearms.
You guys are,
we're invest in nothing underneath.
If you could,
you would frost your hair,
but there's no frosting area and by the way,
you guys are literally spotting each other's hips as you're doing slow grinding.
Pullups oiling your muscles down.
This is the gay,
there's not a girl within fucking five miles.
This is the guy you guys have your appendant area cause you're all top secret.
This is the gayest community I've ever been a part of.
It's luck and all like really good looking young muscular shit dudes who have
names like sparked Spartacus and and and Achilles.
Okay.
Break it down worldwide in this day and age,
how much gay sex is going on and during times of war,
50% about gay sex.
I know that if I was in a foxhole or a prisoner of war camp with you,
I would probably,
I go,
dude,
you smell it.
Men Let me clean your back.
I'm going to scrub your back.
Then you're all dirty on your back area a few months.
He just give up.
That's it.
You just like in the woods.
I just never been attracted to a dude is the only thing.
Although it would have to be a radical changing of your,
uh,
it's like when you start eating squirrels.
Okay.
I try to stay alive here.
He to scroll right now.
Just nip his tail off.
Rats.
Well,
there are some parts of the world actually they eat squirrels on a regular
basis.
Squirrels are actually delicious though.
I mean,
there are a lot of like groups that stay pretty,
I don't think there's a lot of,
you know,
they say that like if you were in a gang,
you're pretty much not fucking each other.
Let's do,
it's aren't fucking around.
I don't know about that.
I don't either.
I don't want to say anything either.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I don't want to either.
I don't know.
I,
you know,
I've always just joked around,
but it's a,
it's a weird thing that humans is more flack that they morph and they just
decide,
okay,
now I'm gay.
Well,
when men are,
you haven't noticed men.
When you get close to a guy,
if you were on a wrestling team or you were on,
you know,
whatever you are,
have you watched like an MMA guys in the back?
You know when,
when they're about to go to fight there,
they're hugging and kissing each other.
You know,
there,
there's a deep,
deep bond that's formed with training and,
and going to war together like that.
And they're,
they're,
they're kissing each other,
they're hugging each other.
No,
it's not.
But I'm saying that that develops it very deep kinship bond.
And if my dick falls in your mouth,
that in my opinion,
is getting ready for a fight.
That does not mean well.
The idea would be that they would fight harder for their lover.
You know,
that would be the idea.
The idea would be that they would fight.
Look Achilles from homer Kelly,
the greatest warrior of mythological times.
His,
his lover's killed.
He had a lover.
He had a male lover and Alexander the great had.
Adam has his best friend and lover.
He killed him apparently when he was drunk in a drunken rage.
But that was his lover that a lot of the great fighters and warriors
traditionally were gay.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Why?
Why did I Alexander lose his temper?
He's only,
he only killed a few thousand people before then.
We're the de killed that guy fucking,
I ain't know it conquered the world.
I mean,
how many people did he killed with his own hands?
Well,
does it,
they don't have anything about that,
but they do know that he was so strong he could be in a full suit of armor and
jump up on his horse.
He was a short guy,
but he was very powerfully built.
What you could jump up onto that he could literally launch himself on.
It was worth a lot of legendary stories about [inaudible] shit.
He was very strong.
He's very squat and think fuck they two small polarize type.
Yeah,
that kind of builds.
That's what I believe.
Just short gorilla.
Like you see his shoulders [inaudible].
Yeah.
You know he's wanting went down to one 70 for tonight's,
I don't know how he looked like death.
It looked like death warmed over,
but looked Fulcan shredded pull,
pull,
pull up an image.
Paul Horez way in p a.
Paul horror is weighing that you see him at one 85 he looks like this giant
Heman and now he's still really muscular.
So my is my weight.
I'm walking at one 70 right now.
Imagine that he's shredded,
shredded,
and then he's going to rehydrate.
He'll probably be at least 10 pounds plus heavier tomorrow,
so he must've,
you were saying that they,
the way a lot of guys lose weight,
they'll drink a lot of water and then that's how you lose the water weight.
There's a lot of shit that has to happen.
You have to get down to a certain target weight before you can lose the
Waterweight.
Like if you're a like say if you're a big strong guy.
Look,
Paul says there's a lot of extra muscle going on there and you,
there's only one way to get rid of that extra muscle.
The muscle,
you have to,
you have to eat,
do it slowly,
or you have to make sure that when you're eating,
you're taking in less calories than you need.
Or if you take in less calories that you need,
you buy starts to eat itself.
Oh,
so you actually have to do,
you do have to restrict your calories that there's,
there are guys who have to do that.
It depends on how big you are and how much you know.
It's
also like,
how'd you get that big like,
and are you still doing whatever you were doing to get that big,
you know,
like what's,
what are your hormones?
Are they being manipulated or the natural?
There's a lot of variables because the assumption always is that someone is
innocent until proven guilty.
So the assumption is always that you're not doing anything unusual.
But when you see like a fucking super strong muscular guy like that,
you always have to remember that there have been people that have been caught
doing drugs.
There have been many,
many,
many ones.
And in fact,
one of them was Paul Harris.
He got caught with the elevated testosterone levels.
So I don't know who is,
and I dunno who isn't it?
That's what it looks like now.
God shredded.
I mean,
that's,
but when he got onto this is like,
he looks okay right there.
I,
I imagine that's before he had his,
uh,
his full,
your buddies,
my friend.
Your it,
how tall is he?
He's,
he's like my,
I probably maybe even shorter than me.
He might be a five,
seven.
He's,
he's such a tank man.
I've never seen a guy that's that successful.
It's that,
that well built,
you know,
that's not a normal frame for a,
um,
an MMA fighter.
No,
that's,
that's a Bot.
That's a body back to his Jujitsu man.
That guy's Jujitsu is fucking ridiculous.
He's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's videos of him,
Roland,
with guys that,
even at the high level guys,
that's what it used to look like at one 85.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's a freak.
Well,
he's got this ability to launch himself onto a submission that you can't stop.
He gets a hold of your leg and it just yanks and spins and it's like a crocodile
got ahold of your leg,
you're fucked.
He just ripped that shit apart.
It was scary because his Jujitsu is very high level.
It's not just that he's super,
super physically strong.
He's,
there's a video of him rolling with some like pretty high level guys and he
takes it,
he takes his guy down,
drop some side control,
spins,
gets his back and chokes him all in like miss it.
Very high level guy.
He was rolling with all in 30 seconds.
Man Runs through the you guys thing of inputting Nam in an arm bar.
Yes.
Yeah.
I talked to mom about that and he was like,
well I was drunk as shit the night before.
So many Ted.
He's still a bad ass.
I'm sure mayhem was,
but I mean who wouldn't lie about that?
But [inaudible] is a beast.
He's a beast.
It's a beast.
His leg locks are fucking things of nightmares.
Yeah.
Nate named Mark Carr when he fought him.
I was talking to him way before he fought him and he said,
the guy's got nasty leg locks,
and all he did was drill,
how to get out of those leg locks,
you know?
Yeah.
And He,
the guy who was pointing to needs legs as if like Nate had oil on them.
I broke a sweat was smart.
That's what you do.
You break a sweat,
you get really sweaty,
like you don't have to be oily if you're just sweaty.
That's good enough,
man.
So they checked his legs and I'm like,
nope.
There's one that was a really weird thing where he pointed and then he got,
and then they just jumped on him.
And that's him getting ivend salivary.
That's his first fight in the UFC.
He took Ivan salivary,
he's back like a ghost.
You better,
you better start tapping.
It takes their back and then he fucking throws that on.
Bottom line is,
yeah,
he's nasty man.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That's a beautiful submission.
So that's what I'm saying about Bahar is like,
he's not just a,
but then he's fighting that dude.
Mike Pierce,
you know that's happening today.
That's today and such on a zeal.
Mike Pierce is a mother fucker dude that,
that guy's on mother fucker.
He's got a head like a fire hydrant.
His heads dot.
Why he punches holes for people's faces and he's tough.
He's shit.
He's a fucking a really strong wrestler.
Like really high level.
He's a credit attacking wrestler.
It's very,
very aggressive wrestler and his game up against the cage drop like drop and
punches in on dudes is very high level.
He can get guys control them up against cage,
beat the shit out of them,
hips up in the air and just start pounding him.
He beats the shit out of you and then takes you down a few times,
beats the shit out of you some more,
but he can knock you out with one punch.
He's got one punch o power.
He's an animal that,
yeah,
so if Paul [inaudible] it's all like,
there's a lot of questions like how much did Paul Horez lose and getting down to
one 70 how much does he have left in the tank?
Because if you lose that much weight,
it's very possible that you did it wrong or it's very possible that it wasn't
really an attainable goal within the time period.
He tried to attain it in.
And so unless you get an expert like a Mike Dolce type guy to go over your
weight cut with you like body fat measurements,
water.
Mike Dolce is a guy who used to fight,
uh,
and he was in the ultimate fighter and then since then he's gone on to be like a
fitness consultant for fighters.
But he's very knowledgeable and very knowledgeable about cutting weight like
his,
the guys who he's trained with that have listened to them and have cut weight
because of his methods of coming in in vastly better condition than they did
when they were doing it on their own.
He's just an expert,
I would knows what he knows where your body's had knows how to give you the
right nutrients,
knows how to give you cut the things out that are going to make your body
naturally lose weight.
And what are the guidelines?
Dolce,
Oh,
I've actually think I've met him.
Well,
what are the,
what are the guidelines for testosterone replacement therapy or hormone replace?
Very good question.
It varies by commissioned.
It varies by,
um,
by country.
It's a,
you're going to have a certain number of nanograms per unit of blood.
It all,
we'll see.
The problem is this is there's a bunch of problems,
but the problem is first and foremost that it's very variable.
B meaning that if you take it,
you are levels between today and tomorrow.
Where they're going to be at depends entirely on when you inject it,
it,
it depends entirely on,
you know,
what kind of stuff you've put in your body,
what kind of testosterone depends on entirely on whether or not you've,
you've injected it or whether you apply it to your skin.
A lot of people just apply it to their skin.
So with all those variables,
there's a lot of room for fuckery.
So what you could do is you could start,
you could start it out with,
I'll give you a way to cheat.
Started out.
We will,
you take the needle every week and you know,
you're only allowed to get x amount per week,
but then every time they're going to test you,
they're going to give you a certain of nowness.
You know,
they,
they can't just show up.
The only people that can just show up or Veda Veda testing or w a da or w a da
or v a,
d,
a w,
either one of those as two different organizations.
And I think both of them do that,
like random thing where they wake you up at eight o'clock in the morning and
tests you.
Wow.
Yeah.
So the problem is if,
if you're willing to gamble,
the way you gamble is you shoot what you're supposed to shoot and then you rub
cream on top of that.
So you have the level that's like really a hard to drop,
which is the injectable level.
The injectable level stays that level for a very long time apparently.
Like if you take it your,
your level,
it'll be in your skin.
You'd be in your system at a certain level of testosterone,
testosterone if for,
it's like a slide.
Yeah.
For like five or six days.
The cream only last 24 hours.
Oh,
so you put the cream on,
your body absorbs it,
and that's a wrap.
So,
so in other words you would put,
if you were injected,
why would the cream on top of that,
when that spike your testosterone to do more hands on whether or not you're
going to get tested,
if you can,
if you can get tested that day,
like say if you wake up in the morning and you know for a fact there's no one
who's going to test you today,
you could rub that cream on your body workout and then probably the next day
you're back down to,
even when you show up at the gym,
they come in and test you.
You're okay.
But meanwhile you have more than the prescribed amount of testosterone cycling
through your system and you're using that extra testosterone,
that extra human level of testosterone as a performance enhancer because you're
recovering in between fights.
Even if when you fight you,
you are fighting and that you get your pee after the fight at a level that's
acceptable.
What was your level throughout the camp?
Sure.
That's what we need to know and it's hard to tell.
You can see,
you know you can have like random ones is all going to be a such ancient history
and about 10 10 years anyway because with gene doping and when they can pinpoint
and they can kind of like block certain amount of Myostatin et cetera and things
in your,
in your jeans and it's safe and it's safe.
Now the question becomes why is it illegal like now it's just a question of who
has the best you can geneticist who has the best doctor to compete.
It's really an interesting thing what it says about competition.
Now as we learn more and more that that winners have to have a certain hardware
and the software is training and stuff,
but without the hardware first,
without that,
the mainframe your fuck Jon Jones has a Ferrari bod.
Correct.
There's no getting past your stupid ass Volkswagen diesel that you have.
There is never going to beat it for right.
It's like this guy in the less the FarEye breaks down.
This is true.
That is just like in,
in the racing,
a guy named Stefan home who is a,
one of the greatest,
greatest high jumper and he's five 11.
Stefan home.
Yeah.
He's a Swedish guy.
Five 11.
He became obsessed with,
um,
high jumping but only was 11.
Most of the hydrogens are six,
seven and stuff.
Really?
Yes.
And he trained and train and train and train and
he became so good and I think he's one,
I look them up,
but I think you want to Olympic gold and several world championships.
His Achilles tendon on his jumping foot is,
can withstand,
it would take 1.8 tons to pull it apart.
Like it's,
it's literally the hardest.
It's three times harder than a regular man's Dick.
Yes.
You can hang it.
Telephone.
Just be it.
Yes.
And so he's trans and he's,
and he,
when he jumps in a,
yeah,
that's him.
Now when he jumps,
his head almost touches,
almost touches his,
uh,
his heels.
That's how flexibly is.
Right.
How long has he,
uh,
w w w and he does this.
He doesn't see you see,
you see the city do this record.
Uh,
I don't,
uh,
I don't know.
But you see how he touches his face like that.
He has a ritual.
He puts his shoes on the same way.
Everything,
right?
No,
it doesn't.
Yeah.
And he jumps high jobs.
Right.
That's insane.
It's ridiculous.
Like a Cheetah now that came from years and years of training and everything
else should show that again.
And he's jumped more.
He's jumped more than anybody in the history of high jumping.
This is insane.
Look how he flies.
Yeah.
And you see how flexible he is.
The thing is tall man,
it's seven foot eight.
Look at that.
That's incredible.
Seven feet,
eight inches or seven,
nine or something.
He's got,
you know.
Wow.
So along comes crazy as fuck man.
Imagine dating that guy.
Yeah.
So along comes this guy from,
from Barbados or something is Canadian.
He's a,
he's this Barbadian guy and he's like six,
uh,
like five or whatever.
And,
and they were talking and he was saying,
um,
he was talking about,
they was like dunking a basketball,
like they've just dunking and crazy ways and he really didn't play much
basketball,
but he was just jumping.
And so he starts talking to this high jumper who says something to the effect
of,
you know,
uh,
yeah,
but high jumping is different.
He goes,
I bet you I could jump over that thing.
And it was six,
five or six,
seven or six.
So be before the day's over,
after like four jumps,
he jumps,
he clears six,
eight,
six inch,
five feet,
eight inches with no technique.
Literally jumping over it.
So,
uh,
the,
the cove track coach comes out and goes,
that's not possible.
Now what are you talking about?
And he goes,
come.
wait,
he's got jumping six had never done,
if that's not possible of how you dramatize these,
like it's an ABC school special.
You put in the dialogue.
Do you have a guy with a different voice to stop Boston?
Both your guy,
you've got to,
you got to delineate the character's man.
I see what you're doing.
He said,
I just not possible rockets.
No Way.
That's not way.
And uh,
he,
he goes out there and sure enough,
this guy jumps I think in eight months of practice and this guy,
Stephen homes,
been practicing his whole life in eight months of practice.
Uh,
and he didn't practice much because he didn't really want to.
It's like whatever.
Uh,
he won the world championships.
He jumped s eight feet already cleared eight feet or something crazy.
It's eight.
Yeah.
Something insane.
Never been done.
Eight months.
Uh,
actually plateaued.
Never got better because he just didn't really want to train much,
but his,
but he had an achilles tendon apparently that was like two times longer than the
average person just born with a certain symmetry.
Wow.
Just,
you know,
just certain mechanics.
Yeah.
And where he was able to jump.
And so no matter how much you trained,
some people are going to jump and run faster.
And you know,
swim panics are gigantic.
One of the really gigantic,
once his punching power,
the mechanics of punching power,
like the natural born punching power.
There's certain guys that,
or are great,
great fighters,
but they just,
perfect example,
Wayne McCullough,
Wayne McCullough is a great fighter,
multiple time champion and a really cool guy on top of that.
And he's a,
I met him a million times,
hang out in Vegas and he's a super,
super good guy.
Wayne McCullough was a bad motherfucker.
He's calling the pocket rocket.
And his,
his number one issue was that he couldn't like knock guys out with one punch.
It wasn't,
you know,
he was,
uh,
like a,
a volume combination,
very technical fighter,
but very,
you know,
just relentless,
relentless boxer,
you know,
just really excellent.
Like if you wanted to learn how to box could watch one of his,
his bouts of Waco,
Wayne McCullough was,
is a style that you could emulate and be like incredibly successful.
He was a beautiful fighter and,
um,
you know,
that kind of a guy.
There's no way they're going to have that sort of Tommy Hearns power.
Like Tommy Hearns had this insane whip power in his right hand that you cannot
teach a guy and you either have that or you don't.
Wayne McCullough was a brilliant,
brilliant fighter,
but the difference between what he could do with one punch and with Tommy Hearns
could do with one punch.
It's like the difference between getting hit with a pebble and getting hit with
a fucking nuclear weapon.
I mean,
getting hit.
A better example is that Macola right there.
Is that Macola?
Yeah,
though that's waned.
Dominating this dude.
He was an animal man who's an amazing fighter that shows show some of this.
We got such shitty resolution.
What's with the gross music behind that?
Is there a soundtrack to this thing and way McCall was an animal.
He would just get on top of dudes.
These fucking Irish fighters.
Oh,
savages.
Barry McGuigan.
He was a savage to savages.
So tough,
tough fucking guys moving his head.
Always stands,
tends to happen.
There's no breaks for you that never stops moving.
No breaks for you son.
Every round was him punching you in the face.
He would just wear on motherfuckers.
Tiny guy too,
right?
It wasn't.
He's not very,
you know,
it doesn't have a very,
have a large frame.
Yeah,
like those,
those kind of guys.
Like,
he'll hit you a bunch of times,
but he'll just continue to hit you at,
you know that.
I mean,
he could certainly knock me out,
you know,
if you're punching in the face clean,
no doubt about that.
But what I'm saying is the difference between what he can do and it got like
Mike Tyson could do it.
Yeah,
you can't teach that Mike Tyson could murder people.
You know?
If you go back to when Mike Tyson beat Michael Spinks and he fucking hit him
with that hook to the body and dropped him.
What happened?
He didn't know what happened.
Spanx got up and then he uppercutted him through the ropes and it was just boom
son.
I've never seen anybody at like,
it was ruthless man.
It was a,
he could just smash you with one shot.
Some guys can do that.
Some guys just can't.
They can't,
they never will be able to.
They just do not have the ability to knock a guy out with one shot.
And if you speed to his ability to turn his body like that,
it's just so ridiculous.
The fights that I would have loved to have seen.
If you could get,
give me a machine that allow me to watch fights,
who throughout history and see who would beat who I would take the Prime Mike
Tyson versus everyone.
That's what I would take.
I would take the Tyson package please.
He'd go back and see Tyson fight.
Jack Johnson.
I want to see Tyson fight.
Jack Dempsey on cm Tyson fight.
Larry Holmes in his frame.
Frasier.
I didn't,
I think homes would have beaten him.
No,
no,
no.
Got That Jab jab he had.
It was,
he was still pretty fucking good when Mike Tyson put them to sleep after two
rounds.
Larry Holmes is still pretty fucking good.
Back then Tyson was something special and Larry Holmes had a,
it was a great,
great,
great boxer.
It's no doubt about it.
It was certainly been much more competitive.
If you've got the,
Larry Holmes had fucked up Gerry Cooney,
if you put that Larry Holmes in with Mike Tyson,
that's a different Larry Holmes.
By the time they fought,
Larry was 36 years old.
He started to,
you know,
hit a long structure.
Good fighter.
He,
he's in the Pantheon of great fighters.
Larry Holmes without question,
who his boxing is,
you know,
well,
some of the best heavyweight divisions,
Molly's sparring partner,
if you,
if you watch that movie when we were kings,
Larry Holmes is his,
is his number one sparring partner you ever seen?
Well,
in,
in a lot of ways.
Larry Holmes in history doesn't get the respect that he's due because he came
after Ali.
Yeah.
And he was the guy who beat up Ali when he beat up,
I'll leave.
People never forgave him for that and he didn't.
Meanwhile,
he knew all these so well they had been,
they,
they'd been sparring partners and yeah,
and those,
those last days of Ali,
those should be the last days of Ali's career should be followed by every boxer
very close with a fine tooth comb.
So this is Larry when he had already,
but you know what?
Here's another thing.
Here's the real deal.
Larry did not face the kind of opposition that Mike Tyson did.
He just didn't,
he just didn't,
you know,
Larry fought a lot of good guys but his division was particularly weak and when
Tyson came along it was like pink land,
Thomas,
Tony Tubs,
all these guys that they were just,
they were very good fighters but they just weren't like this motherfucker.
Look at how,
look at how fast Tyson was.
He was scared and his ship work was amazing to look at us and he just had to hit
you once and he was so good at that bobbing and weaving style.
He got a lazier as he got further away from the custom auto training from
testimony I,
they said that was the beginning of the end for him also left Rooney when he
rapped left Rooney,
you know,
those guys had a falling out and then we'll,
that Pico was down from chat style and he also got away from someone who's not
bullshitting him.
And that's what happened.
And that's where he went from being the greatest in the world to like slowly but
surely getting beaten by guys.
And then the buster Douglas fight,
which is like the perfect storm.
Douglas comes in and Douglass,
his mother just died and he did not give a fuck and he wasn't scared at all.
He lost his mother,
so she just came in and boxed it.
Huge man,
by the way,
like I was watching him Jad Tyson and Tyson,
his head go back like that.
You see Tyson's head snap back as as busted,
busted.
It's just throwing those amazing jabs.
Who Buster Douglas in that like when he went in that fight put on one of the
greatest performances in boxing history.
It was brilliant.
It wasn't just brilliant because he was fighting Mike Tyson.
It was brilliant,
period.
It was a tremendous fight.
He finally fought up to his potential.
Buster Douglas was always a talented guy.
That was a little kind of a little lazy,
but not in this fight and this fight.
He fought like a fucking king.
He hooked off the jab better than anybody I've ever seen heavyweight divisions
to the way he hooked off the jab though,
Dude.
I mean it was like really like Ali ask.
Yeah,
I mean it was beautiful.
He was firing the Jab and hooking off it and the fucking power bomb left hook
that starts this off.
Watch this shit.
Look at this jabbing,
just tagging them.
Tagging.
Scanning is fixed that look at that left.
Oh,
he catches him with that right upper cut first and then that power left.
I mean that is a fucking beautiful combination man and heavyweight boxing.
There've been very few combinations that were that gorgeous to watch on the
watch that again,
put that lievable.
Just the way he fires in the jabs,
he's firing jabs in on Tyson's face,
sets him up for the uppercut lays.
A trap for him was fires in these jabs on them,
lays the trap for them and then sends the upper cut up the middle.
What's his top when he finally fires this off?
Man,
that's,
that's like it's,
it's one of the great performances,
man.
Look,
Jab,
boom.
Oh,
I mean there's a hook trap for him.
God,
he set a trap for him with that upper cut.
Yup.
That was a beautiful combination and that's just an example of a guy.
I mean,
he might not have been able to maintain that.
He might not have maintained it after he made so much money off of it.
This fight and after the Holyfield fight,
they had lost at the moment and yet at the moment of greatness,
I mean he made a tremendous amount of money and maybe he just,
after his mom died,
he didn't want to do it anymore.
Maybe the Tyson fight was just such a high water mark that he was done,
but no one can take this away from buster Douglas that this night.
It wasn't just that he was fighting and undertrained Tyson.
It wasn't just that he was fighting a guy who underestimated him.
It was that he came to give zero fucks.
He came to give zero fucks and show what he's capable of and he trained like a
motherfucker for this fight.
He came in in incredible shape throwing bombs here.
I think it was in the 10th with these stop them in the 10th round.
A lot of guys that came in against Tyson that we're already a beat too.
I mean,
a lot of ways.
They were just so afraid of his punching power.
I believe it was the 10th I believe it was late in the fight and was also,
by the way,
after buster Douglas had been knocked down.
Yeah,
it was the 10th I remember I was so knocked down,
I think in the eighth of the night.
I didn't know that.
Yeah,
you got dropped twice and clipped him with an upper cut and had him hurt.
Look,
man,
that was a fucking master full performance and it wasn't the right Tyson.
I mean,
I would've loved to see that buster Douglas again said Tyson had fought Marvis
Davis,
marvelous phrase.
She said that he wasn't training as much as he should have then,
and that was when he was starting to get called the scariest all time.
Tyson was the Tyson that was still trying to prove himself.
If you look for Tyson versus Marvis Frasier,
that's the mother fucker.
That's the man.
That's the boogeyman.
Yeah.
Because you watch Tyson and you've for,
you see Marvins Frazier across the ring from him and you see Tyson warming up
and you're like,
I'm about to witness an execution.
And you see Joe Frazier trying to pump it sun up,
tell us on the box,
and that guy walks in there and he can barely breathe because he knows what's
going to happen.
I mean,
he's so nervous.
He's in the ring with the peak Tyson,
the peak ferocity,
because the peak really wasn't even after he had become the champion.
The peak was on its way up.
Aw,
look at him.
Look at him.
They're going to build on him.
It's ridiculous.
I want to know how you think he'd do an MMA against guys like John Jones.
This was before he fought for the title.
I'm,
I'm pretty sure,
let me,
uh,
absolutely,
I believe it was when he was on his way up and everybody was shitting their
pants because he was on like ABC.
I think this was,
look at Joe Frazier.
Look at it.
If they're like twins,
they're like twins,
man.
He and his dad.
Joe Frazier was a great fighter.
Look at his dad and his dad right behind him.
Yeah,
it looks just like them,
but Marvis was like more slight in frame.
It's not that slight.
Well more slight than him.
Not like compared to you.
It's true.
Look at that.
Look at Tyson.
Tyson has just built to administer an ass kicking.
Look at that.
Look at,
he's like,
it's like a joke.
He's like a cartoon character.
He actually fought twice after that before you won the title.
So you're dealing with a guy who was 20 years old here.
This is a,
this is up.
Jumped the boogeyman.
I didn't have the look on [inaudible] face was Fraser box.
Not Long.
No.
I think this was it for him.
He might've fought one or two times two wealthy or something.
Well,
this is a terrible beating.
This is my growing up too wealthy.
Maybe,
you know,
whatever.
There's no way he was going to be this guy.
This is a look at this.
This was two completely different types of human beings here.
Look at this fight,
and this is an assault.
This is not a boxing match.
This is a boxing match between the son of one of the greatest fighters of all
time and a murder,
whatever,
up to a scene.
Frasier and his private fight him.
Yeah,
but could you imagine the horror of being a guy like Frasier and seeing your son
just get destroyed?
Look at the movement of Tyson as he sets himself up for those punches.
That's another thing.
Take a look at that.
Again,
back got up just the last combination when he cracks him just to watch the feet
of Tyson as he's throwing these shots,
he's adjusting constantly as he's throwing these bombs,
look at this,
look at this.
Boom.
Watch this.
Move backwards,
backwards,
boom,
boom.
Cause he's little subtle movements to get her stuff into perfect position.
That was part of the genius at Tyson that a lot of people don't notice when a
lot of people watch guys punch,
they assume that he's just standing there punching the guy.
No chance,
no.
He's constantly moving.
He's just always in the absolute perfect position to punch.
So as he's unloading these combinations,
he's moving back slightly back in.
There's a genius and a brilliance to Tyson's destruction of Marvis Frazier and a
lot of other people that a lot of other fighters that people don't respect or
understand because they don't know how difficult it is to just just a punch.
A guy standing in front of you this many times and the way Tyson is doing it
with movement is ridiculous.
Look at this.
Boom,
boom.
Now Watch his feet,
man.
Watch he slides back and then perfect position paying perfect position and then
he looks at my offices.
Heads swings again,
sets them up,
Bang right hand.
It's almost the left is measuring the right being left hand.
Everything is perfect.
The the accuracy of both the hands and the feet is stunning.
It's a masterful there.
Dot.
United.
Just excellent.
He was very technical.
He's an excellent technical bug.
That's what they said,
how hard he worked at at footwork and there was a perfect execution or he was a
perfect issue.
Schnur is perfect.
It looks more muscular there then.
Then anytime in his career that's up jumped the boogie man,
Mike Tyson.
That's when Mike Tyson was the scariest motherfucker ever,
ever forget about Sonny Liston.
Forget about Jack Dempsey.
Forget about Jack Johnson.
They were all great,
but that Mike Tyson was the scariest motherfucker of all time.
That was the boogeyman.
I never saw that.
I actually never saw it.
He almost died.
He was a destroyer man.
Tomorrow you would you agree with them at this point?
Most definitely.
Anytime.
If my manager and my train and filled out,
I'm confident and they're willing to put me in a title and I show I could beat
the champion.
I'm sure I could beat him off though.
Of the three champions,
who would you like to fight?
Anybody my trainer put me in with because I'm coughing now.
Could be any fight in the world.
What do you think of the three champions?
Don't have good fight it because there have to be a good fight.
He can't take nothing away from it to become the champion,
but I'm confident I'm ready and I'm ready with my trainer tells me what am I
going?
Let's take a look at the green.
In my opinion,
this guy,
that guy does not get all the respect that he deserves.
I think he's the greatest boxer of all time.
I think in that time period,
I think Mike Tyson is the greatest boxer of all time because he's not just,
he's not just a great destroyer.
If you're watching how he's landing these combinations and how he can force his
will on fighters.
In my opinion,
he's the most devastating boxer period that's ever existed,
but it just,
he couldn't continue it for a long time.
Right.
You gotta like put it in perspective of what he was capable of doing just
because he was only capable of doing it for a few years.
It doesn't mean he didn't do it like people try to judge people all overall on
their overall career.
I don't because I as a person who's had some competition in my life,
I know how difficult it is to maintain even the mediocre level of performances
that I achieved and I know that to be a world champion like Mike Tyson,
the training alone is sole nominee.
It requires madness wires.
Matt,
what do you think of that?
Tyson with someone like crushes everybody.
What about well,
right today a um,
what's
crushes him?
You think so rush,
crush the Mike Tyson of up up jumped the boogie man.
Mike Tyson runs through Klitschko like a wolf through a pack.
A sheep really?
I think he crushes all of them.
Even lending flu.
I just think there was a time period where he could not be beat Max Lewis as
well.
For one I've seen,
I've never seen anybody go through people like he went through Frank Bruno,
like he went through last and razor Reddick was a giant.
Never put razor radical away.
No,
but he knocked them across the literally knock them across.
You know who put him away?
Tommy Morrison.
Toni Morrison,
Tommy Mars last.
Hillary Odom.
He left hooked them.
Questionable Stockbridge.
A bit of a question.
We'll stop it.
Yeah.
He unloaded a combination that I didn't think he could have.
Let it go on a little bit.
I think maybe they want to tell you to win a little bit.
Little bit.
Ben,
he's the guy looked okay.
He looked okay to me.
I've seen latest stoppages is all I'm saying.
So all I'm saying fix could have been in,
I think Mike Tyson,
if you put them in,
like if you had a time machine and you could get all the money from 1926 or
whatever the Fuck Jack Dempsey was the champ and put them in with Mike Tyson.
Just bring bikes like Mike Tyson would run through him.
I don't know enough about,
I would never been,
Kate said,
I've never seen anybody from with my eyes hit harder than Mike Tyson.
It's not just hitting,
well I think guys probably hit harder like Earnie shavers.
Earnie Shavers was a far,
is built different,
couldn't move as fast and it wasn't just the fact that Tyson could hit you so
hard and we see he was so accurate and that's what people don't understand.
There's a brilliance to his movement.
It's not just punching power.
There's been guys that have ridiculous punching power or any shavers is one.
Oh,
people always bring up Tommy Hearns is another one.
Ridiculous punching power in the heavyweight division.
There's quite a few guys.
George Foreman,
of course.
Great.
One of the greatest punching power guys of all time.
It's not just punching power.
Tyson says the brilliance of his movement mechanics,
an accuracy of that combination that's just spectacular.
It's amazing to watch.
It's real artwork too.
For a guy who knows how difficult it is to land shots like that on a moving
opponent.
Having seen so many different fights in my life,
I never seen a striker that could fuck with Prime Mike Tyson.
I think it was the perfect combination of emotions and this massive desire to be
loved and needed and perfect athleticism,
ridiculous genetics and genetics will willpower and the perfect trainer in the
perfect moment of his life,
like a movie man,
custom model was a boxing genius.
A guy would been around the sport his whole life and he saw this kid and he was
like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to take this kid in.
Like he hasn't had anybody like that for a long period of time.
From um,
the,
the dude that about Floyd Patterson,
he had Floyd Patterson back in the day and then he had,
um,
the,
uh,
light heavyweight champion.
I'll leave for a while.
No,
no,
that's not,
yeah,
just done.
D custom auto had a,
he had Floyd Patterson that was like his,
probably his most famous fighter and he had,
um,
Jose Torres,
the guy went and wrote a tell all book about Mike Tyson,
the young like Tyson.
Um,
and then he had Tyson and he knew when he had ties.
Yeah,
Teddy Atlas of course two and a couple of other guys.
And Teddy was working with him back then.
But do you hear the Tyson in the up jumped the boogie man.
Mike Tyson,
when he's talking after,
he's like,
you know,
he's,
he's confident but he's not crazy.
He's not eat your babies yet.
Right?
He's not,
I'm a pet you if I can't be,
be,
and can we get starved?
I each a chilled drink that Mike Tyson,
that was a different Mike Tyson that was in Mike Tyson who was already red
lined.
He'd already seen too much.
He'd already been through too much.
You'd already partied too hard.
He'd already,
he'd already lost $300 million.
So there was already two months losing that much money by the crazy,
crazy life around him.
Million Dollars.
So what do you,
how do you lose?
I think it was like when you see him there,
in there,
in that image and then up jumped the boogie man.
He's a young man,
he's living in the Catskills in New York in an old man's house and he's being
taken care of like a,
a plot,
a prime like at like the best prodigy of,
of master could ever have in his last days of life.
It's like an incredible story that's out of a movie.
You have a boxing master who's not just the boxing master,
but a master of psychology and the psychology of combat sports.
And he has stories to go along with every one of his lessons and he puts this
kid in harm's danger in harm's way over and over again,
slowly but surely an amateur boxing competitions while teaching him all these
psychological principles.
And this kid can recite them back and forth with you.
And as long as he's under the tutelage of this great master,
he's almost invincible.
And then right after his master dies,
that's when shit starts getting crazy.
That's when he loses himself.
And that's when he's not,
he's not that same guy after years and years of not being around cussing
anymore.
Not having that sort of relationship or figure,
not just a father figure,
but,
uh,
the masterful mentor that every young athlete wishes he came across when he was
an orphan.
I mean,
his,
his story is so incredibly unique,
you know,
and I think they did a good job of,
of touching on certain aspects of it.
And that movie with Michael Jai White,
you know,
Michael John [inaudible],
I could drive.
Why did a great job,
he's a bad motherfucker.
And you know,
you believe in,
when you look at him that he's a beast.
You know,
Michael J.
White,
he's a really talented striker.
Like if,
you know,
you've ever seen that guy work out before?
I've seen the actor.
Yeah.
Tyson.
Oh really sad.
A lot of coke or Christian fights.
Oh really?
A lot of them.
Yeah.
And he's,
he's a legit black belt and be like several different,
I think more than one different martial art.
He's a legit blackbelt.
Wow.
Yeah.
There's also,
you seem like you've ever watched those videos where he's done a bunch of
martial arts movies.
You see Michael Jai white throat kicks like that.
Motherfucker's got perfect technique with everything he does.
He's like a really high level black belt and striking.
Wow,
so his movements when he walked,
you watched him play tight.
It wasn't offensive,
but I don't think they captured the madness.
That was his childhood and how it led to beat him.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe if I went back again and I would say that it just forgot about it because
I remember the box can,
I don't think a two hour movie will can capture what
what forges someone like a phenomenon like Mike Tyson.
The movies never going to capture the real thing.
Nobody would have thing that we just watched.
What's amazing about it is not just the fact that we were watching a Guy Punch a
guy and do all this.
There's the fact that it actually happened.
That is a video of reality that took place that's undeniable and we saw
something incredibly special happened.
I think what's even just as amazing in some ways to fish from an American like
phenomenon,
you know as a,
as a,
as a figure of the 20th century is the fact that he has a one man show that
sells out all over the world in theaters.
Dude,
I have a picture with him is like one of the happiest moments in my life.
Me like first of all,
if you go to that show,
no,
he was at the UFC and the UFC many times I've got a picture of him.
I put it on the Instagram and it was like,
I've never been more proud.
He knows who you are
and that's the same kind of,
that's the same thing as where Laurence Fishburne came up to me and he goes,
I want to meet Joe Rogan man.
Bring them over.
I was like going to be my buddy.
I'm sure he'd love to meet you.
That was so weird,
man.
I'm telling you that because I'm a fan man.
You were like,
yeah,
well I'm a fan of here.
That's Morpheus.
Morpheus,
Levy's.
Yeah.
That was really cool.
It was.
He's a very nice guy.
He's a great guy,
man.
I spent two months with them coming out in the movie.
I'm so proud to be in a movie with Laurence Fishburne,
man.
I'm,
I'm always like,
there's certain guys like that level,
like you're always like,
wow,
I can't even believe I'm talking to you.
Nick Knowlton pretty well.
Nick naulty is the most down to Earth motherfucker you will ever meet Nick Nolte
to I ran into him at Fry's electronics and uh,
it's like,
oh hey Jola when you're buying a video card for my kid,
you're not.
Do you know anything about these things?
Like had like a list and his glasses,
his son was really into computers.
He's hooking to sun up some stuff for his computer fries.
If you've never been there,
it's like fucking key.
Kevin,
have you ever been there?
I've been there with you 1516 years ago and I never forgot this.
This is literally 16,
17 years ago.
And you were not only were you on the internet or something,
but you,
you,
you literally went to get a more memory for your computer and you came out with
a switchboard.
I'll never forget this.
I was like,
dude,
this guy's a genius.
He must be a scientist.
Like I was like more memory for here.
I didn't even know what the fuck you were talking about.
And you bought like a switchboard that you were going to put into your computer.
Well,
it's just memory sticks.
It's not difficult.
That's strange to me.
I remember just clip it in place and it's not hard.
Memory is one of the easiest things to ever.
You were online so far,
you were on line five years before I even had an email.
Well,
I was online because my friend Robbie Printz,
Robbie Printz,
a hilarious comedian from Boston that I came up with and Robbie was a,
he sold computers,
uh,
before he became a comedian.
And so when we were starting out together,
we were both in California around the same time.
They were on 94.
Um,
he was out here doing some stand up and I,
I was out here and um,
he took me to an apple store.
No,
it wasn't even an apple store.
It was comp USA might not have even been apple stores back then.
And I don't remember who took me to buy my first computer.
Yeah,
I remember that.
totally.
I was like,
you don't get online bitch.
Massive.
We should buy it.
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Yeah,
I can get this,
get this,
get this.
Walked out with like some crazy amount of money.
Right.
You know,
it was like,
it's up was a smart move though and you need to get on it more.
You're really bad with your,
we were talking about this like tweets promoting yourself and tweeting and stuff
and also you've got a lot to say,
man.
You know what?
I'm glad you're finally doing that in these podcasts and I think you should
write two.
I am writing.
You should write a blog.
No,
and I,
I,
you know,
I'm really excited.
The podcast thanks to you,
like just having done it and what I like the difference is what I do is I'll
take,
I read a book that I think is great and I get the,
if the,
if I think it's somebody who's got something to say,
um,
I will put him on the podcast and I had these conversations with these fucking
award winning historians like Charles Mann of just,
I just did a pockets.
This guy wrote 1491 1493 sort of the world before Columbus.
And the Shit I learned about like,
just like basically things like why in the south black they use black labor as
opposed to white indentured servants was because they were resistant to malaria.
They were just able to add a genetic like resistance or the fact that that uh,
tomatoes and potatoes,
you know where they come from South America and Europe,
Italian food for 500 years is basically fusion cuisine.
The Italian didn't grow tomatoes until they got them from South America.
Yeah.
Potatoes change the landscape cause he grow the hunter to,
when did they get the tomato?
The Colombian exchange in the 1,402 when,
when,
when Spaniards and,
and you know,
and the French and w work coming into South America and this area and they,
and they would bring pigs with them so they could eat him on board.
The pigs would get off with escape into the forest.
They carry a lot of communicable diseases to humans.
That's how they think.
A lot of a lot of these communities,
these vast communities of Indians and Charles c man said that there may have
been up to 50 to 80 million inhabitants of the United States when white people
first came here.
How about that?
That's what most,
this is the kind of shit I'm talking about.
So,
so,
you know,
you hear about this stuff and they were all decimated by,
by,
by disease.
I mean literally it could have been as easy as when they were coming up the
Mississippi Delta with their pigs.
It could have been 60 people brought diseases that no one had any,
no one had any fucking,
you know,
a resistance to,
they all died.
So when they came back,
the entire area was abandoned.
It was just clay pottery and stone and nothing was there
crazy because you know we were always taught that there was nobody here.
Oh,
just a few Indians,
50 to 80 million according to the latest estimates by historians now and
archeologists paleontologist.
So
the numbers are vastly larger than we thought and that,
I mean a good percentage of it was straight genocide.
Well,
I mean there was,
there's a lot of genocide involved as well,
but my brand,
that trail of tears and all the,
I mean even long before that they still have reservations to this day.
Long before that though was disease.
What they think is that disease really truly decimated 90% of the population.
But you know what?
I don't think it's even important to differentiate.
What we don't actually know long before was disease.
But we do know two things took place.
Hideous histories,
way too muddy I think to do that.
But I think we do know two things.
We know they definitely got a lot of diseases from Europeans and they definitely
were murdered by Europeans.
We know both.
So I think when you say,
well,
this happened first,
and that happens second boy that gets squirrely when you're talking about 1492
that it gets real squirrely,
very warlike with each other.
By the way.
I mean,
they were savages,
Columbus and those people were all fucking savage.
It's so straight.
Slavery was the order of the day.
One of the great turning points in history was the abolitionist.
A worldwide abolition is moving the worldwide movement to end slavery was done.
So like nobody thought these were like fanatical.
Usually religious people at the most part.
Slavery,
if you think about it,
throughout the history of human was the order of things.
It was just the birth.
You took everyone from Aristotle,
Socrates,
they all had slaves.
I mean,
it went all the way up until the idea that you could actually change the,
the,
the how we look at human humanity as you're not channeled.
You don't,
you shouldn't belong to somebody.
Wasn't was so not in people's Pantheon.
You,
when you were conquered by another army,
you were simply sold into slavery.
Uh,
Constantinople,
which was a society,
a civilization stand that stood for a thousand years.
It was the,
the heart of Christianity when it fell in the 14 hundreds feet entire,
those that weren't put to the sword,
the rest of them,
probably 50 to a hundred thousand,
which is sold into slavery.
And that was the order.
That's what you did.
So sorry.
I know you've got a family and stuff were taking your kids stop it,
you know,
and you just,
the brutality is beyond what,
you know,
people come in and again,
I think it has to do with what people are used to,
that that was what they grew up with.
That's what they saw.
That's what they were used to.
There was when you were talking about Lincoln's kids dying and that was even
worse back then.
Short way,
we're sure there was a wellspring of misery.
You know,
where,
where if you had an abscess in your tooth or rheumatoid arthritis in bitch,
it's a wrap.
You Die.
Yeah.
You get staph infection,
take care of and he scratch.
You get from hammering nails to try to build the house to keep your children,
but you might lose your hand.
That's right.
Soon as possible.
And that was it.
But,
but what,
what the other side of it was that kind of contact with humanity was a great
deal of trade and,
and so potatoes kept Europeans alive for it because you grow on the ground,
they're not as vulnerable as wheat.
Wheat in the wind will answer.
You get a hailstorm,
potato Stan to the ground.
When a marauding army comes in to take all your shit.
They,
they're not looking at the ground.
You
got all your food and a sweet potato,
a and even a potato.
But you can,
you can basically with a sweet potato and with milk,
with milk products,
you can live,
you could thrive.
So you had entire communities in Europe who were building and the Europe was
built essentially all of Europe was built not just on bread,
but on potatoes.
When potatoes came in and tomatoes and,
and you had milk products like cheese,
you're basically fine.
You will,
you will be fine.
You'll grow into a big strong boy.
Well,
nutrition is such an underrated aspect of like why people succeed and why they
failed.
And not just in,
in terms of like nations,
but in terms of human beings that,
you know,
like the people that take care of their nutrition and,
and give their body nutrients,
their bodies work better,
their brain works better,
they make more sense.
It's really that simple.
One of the turning points in American history was when we got rid of oak warm,
there's a scorge of hookworm in the south after the,
after the civil.
Do you know that they're trying to give people hookworm to cure asthma.
Really did.
Yeah.
Cause it makes you worry me make,
there's something that happens with hookworm.
That's a quorum stops asthma.
And so there was a doctor that was trying to inject hookworm into a chronic
asthmatic cause they get into your feet.
Dr Infects himself with Hookworm for health experiments.
Um,
this guy had,
so he swallowed,
he swallowed,
um,
a camera to,
to,
to film the action in his stomach.
He infected himself.
His name is Dr. James Logan.
In fact it himself with these hookworms and then swallowed a pill,
a little tiny pill camera to find the action in his gut.
That's how that guy's bad ass dude.
That guy's gangster.
That's a doctor that did that.
Quorums make you anemic.
They,
they,
they rob your body of iron and you have no energy.
So say straight dope.
We'll hook worms.
Relieved my asthma.
Wow.
What's it say?
That's awesome.
Let me,
the body don't took Quinten [inaudible] and his team.
I've lined up a spatial scanner which can see through the top layers of Dr.
Logan skin before placing a water droplet containing 50 hookworm larvae onto his
own.
Cause I have a right to your arm.
Into my skin,
like straight away or is it going to take well thanks.
We don't really know.
So let's,
let's just,
okay.
Apparently whether or not this has nothing to do with whether or not hookworm
cures asthma.
Unfortunately just hookworm it's in this guy's body that they can see what the
camera,
they were a real score and once they created outhouses,
when people aren't going to the bathroom and the great outdoors,
cause everybody walked around in bare feet,
it,
it changed the entire landscape of the south and changed their entire economy.
Because you had communities where 90% of the people who are anemic and had no
energy to work from hookworm.
That's incredible.
That changes your whole changed everything.
Everything you human being as a machine,
you,
if you,
if you're not gonna be able to take care of the pathogens,
the diseases and stuff,
and people don't feel good,
they're not going to be able to do anything.
It's like the importance of sleep.
I'm having a sleep expert on the podcasts because sleep is way more important
than,
than they thought.
Way more important too.
We are all chronically understaffed.
If you're not sleeping and hydrated,
then everything else falls out that you can everything else,
you know,
and I encourage people this and I can't stop saying it.
I'll say it again if you can.
If you have access to an isolation tank,
please do it.
Please.
The relaxation that you get from one hour of a sensory deprivation tank is like
sleeping the best eight hours of your life.
I got to get your body feels so loose and good when they get out of there.
It's amazing.
And you've never had to change the water because nothing,
she just changed the water.
Yeah.
It only lasts like a couple of years and you have to swap it out.
I mean,
I've had it,
I've had it for five years the most I think I've ever had,
but crash the guy who runs the float labs a heel,
he services that.
If you have a unit in your house,
he comes to my house and get services.
The place to go though is near you.
I mean,
you can go to float lab.com it's in Venice.
Yep.
Been there.
I loved it.
And by the lock and incredible thought I'd be there like I thought I could only
stay there for a half hour.
I'd be like,
I'd get bored.
Two hours went by.
I didn't even know.
You know,
you should be doing that all the time,
dude.
You should be doing that all the time.
You should.
You've got some cash.
You should get one of those in your fucking house.
You really should just one of the greatest things you could ever have.
I mean,
I have access to the most incredible environment on earth in my house on a
regular basis.
It's changed who I am as a human being.
And when I,
when I get away from it and I don't do it for a while,
I start getting squirrelly.
It's like a need.
It,
it's like I need to get back in there.
It's,
it's a balancing.
Where'd you,
uh,
like learn about where,
where did,
where did you when I saw that movie with,
um,
what the fuck is my altered states?
Kind of.
Oh yeah.
That's a,
that's a come on.
Um,
yeah.
William hurt.
Is it?
Yup.
Yes.
It's William Hart.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Yup.
And that's a terrible movie by the way.
I try watching it now.
Oh,
God doesn't hold up at all.
It's terrifying.
I was like,
how did I think this was good?
What was I retarded back then?
Like,
it's almost like I'm,
I'm,
I'm a emerging from my own ea idiotic shell.
Cause I,
it's,
there's weird things about these movies that we just accepted a few years ago.
This is a him,
it's based on the work of a great man,
a fascinating man name.
Um,
uh,
just the fuck's his name,
John Lilly,
Jesus Christ.
Um,
and John Lilly,
uh,
wrote the deep self,
which is a fascinating,
okay.
I have took on,
on floating and uh,
he also invented the sensory deprivation tank and Lilly,
uh,
did a lot of weird shit like interspecies communication work with dolphins where
he'd take acid and,
and uh,
put himself in a sensory depth tank near a were dolphins live.
He did a lot of freaky shit.
And um,
his work was,
you know,
he was known to be like one of the most daring of the psychedelic adventures.
Lilly was thought to be like a true madman.
Like he would shoot ketamine and get into the sensory depth tank.
That was the big thing with them.
My friend Todd actually has Lily's tank.
He actually owns Lily's tank.
Lily gave it to him and the first time he ever went into a tank,
lily put him in his tank.
Lily had two tanks side by side and they would do ketamine together.
Ketamine is,
it's a fucking cat tranquilizer.
It's a,
it's a psychedelic apparently,
but a very dangerous one.
Very hardcore,
very addictive one,
by the way.
Not just psychologically,
but physically addictive.
One of the rare,
physically addictive psychedelics.
And um,
apparently Lilly loved it.
And the way it's described by Mckenna,
I've never experienced a ketamine,
but Wade Mckenna describes it,
is he believes that one of the things you get in a psychedelic,
like a mushroom,
is that you're not just getting a substance interacting with your brain.
You're actually getting a database of experiences.
And that's one of the reasons why when you take Iowasca,
you see Jaguars and black people and snakes is because that's what they see in
the forest.
In the forest.
They see Jaguars,
they see black people and they see snakes.
That's who lives in the forest.
So when you take it,
you're literally not just taking this substance and interact with your brain.
You're also taking this incredible database of experiences,
which is why so many people have extremely similar accounts of the trip.
The trip reports are very similar when it comes to Iowasca and the idea is
ketamine.
The idea is that ketamine is a very recent drug,
so the amount of trips are very small.
So when you do the ketamine trip,
it's not this overwhelming rush of Mondalez and patterns in geometry and,
and information and Egypt and iconography and you don't get that.
And Ketamine,
you can't like an empty building,
like you're in some,
some strange place,
but you're the only one.
They're like,
you're going through these giant empty and occasionally someone's watching you.
Occasionally you'll see like a lurker who's re looking behind walls and there
they're paying attention to you,
but it's like you're in this freaky psychedelic journey where very few people
have gone before.
So you might not even encounter other experiences or travelers,
but if you do it together with someone apparently can go somewhere together.
And this is what lily used to do.
Little used to like he,
he asked my friend,
he goes like,
do you want to,
you want to do ketamine with this?
Cause it was the first time they'd ever done,
um,
isolation tank.
He's like,
sure.
You know,
like,
he's like,
I couldn't say no to John Lilly who's holding a fucking syringe full of
ketamine.
He had a prep for him and he's like,
Bam,
I would have hit some intramuscularly.
And then just,
and then apparently my friend was like yelling some shit out.
I don't know,
Todd McCormick is,
he's much better at telling the story than I am.
But he apparently had yelled out and so lily went to go like rescue him.
So Lilly banged himself with the ketamine,
gets in the tank next to him,
his two tanks Hopsin the second tank and meets them on whatever fucking channel
he's on.
Wow.
Yeah.
And he like literally has a physical memory of Lilly coming and communicating
with him in this ketamine world.
Wow.
That's also been established of certain tryptamines like um,
Iowasca.
Um,
the,
one of the elements in Iowasca is this,
this plant,
this chemical called harming.
And when they first identified it,
they were going to call it telepathy scene because it didn't,
they,
when they took it together,
they encountered this group,
state of telepathy that they all recounted.
They all recounted the same experiences while they were taking this Iowasca,
these early p or similar enough in their description because there are so
fantastical.
It was hard to really wrap your head around exactly what you saw.
But it was similar enough that they were convinced that they were having some
sort of a group psychedelic experience.
And it supports the idea that when you take a psychedelic drug,
it's not simply that you are,
your brain is interacting with a chemical because in reality that's all your
brain does all day.
It reacts to Stimuli.
Relapse reacts to love,
reacts to hate,
reacts to stress,
Cortisol levels,
adrenaline.
There's a constant soup of chemicals that are influencing whether or not you
think one way or another,
whether or not you get excited,
whether or not you stay calm.
So the idea is that this one chemical,
which is produced by the human brain and is so closely replicated by DMT,
by a Iowasca buy mushrooms,
like mushrooms are really similar in like their chemical structure to DMT.
So the,
the fact that mushrooms are really similar to natural human neurochemistry is
pretty fucking freaky.
And the fact that when you take these things,
you have these uh,
these weird interdimensional hallucinations where you feel like you'd go
somewhere.
I had a,
I had the weirdest thing when I took mushrooms.
I took a three hour shower and I,
I kept seeing myself from the side.
Like I kept seeing my profile,
which was terrible.
I was like,
it was a terrible profile has to do is think about that and it's disastrous
profile.
But I have,
I have,
my chest is going in,
I got a barrel it out.
I got a lot of bench to do a,
and then I kept seeing somebody in the corner with a whip,
like who was kind of telling me to tell the truth.
You know,
what wasn't whipping me.
But [inaudible] is like this.
I kept feeling this presence of,
uh,
this person with a whip saying,
you know,
I think it was my,
my,
the,
the side of me that was the truth and not lying.
You know,
I realize that a lot of my life was a lie.
Um,
cause I was young,
I was young trying to do,
I was living other people's lives.
So it was,
I was doing,
listening to other people and it was a very,
very profound trip in a sense.
And I actually,
uh,
af after I got back to normal,
the next day I had a,
I kind of did a real reassessment of my life.
I have to say,
I,
I kind of was like,
I'm not going to be,
I'm going to do what I want to do and listen to my own inner compass.
And I haven't been doing that.
Yeah.
Well you're very different than when you were,
when I first met you.
You very different.
You're very different in your good.
Yes.
Much,
much,
much better.
And not that there's anything wrong with you.
Back then,
you were awesome.
I'd so if I met you in 1994 today,
if I met the 1994 cal and I would still be your best friend.
It's not that you were no,
but I know you were way more,
um,
under the control of other people that are directed.
Yeah,
it was weird.
Like,
and I,
I've always been
that I had that luxury.
You didn't,
so,
so the world was a dangerous place for you.
I had a lot of fall backs and I think it allows you the luxury of not having to
think for yourself.
I think that one of the,
one of the,
um,
one of the fallbacks of having,
you know,
a supportive home structure is,
which is a good thing,
but you know,
when you have to fend for yourself in a lot of ways.
And I did to an extent,
but,
but you know,
I always say to young people,
it's normal when you're young to be overwhelmed by forces,
you can't explain.
It is a lot of mystery in the world and you will be directed other other ways.
And your job as you get older is to find out who you are and what you're
supposed to do and where you're supposed to place your energy on your own terms.
That is the communion you have with yourself,
that that is the,
that is the idea.
So that,
you know,
for me now at this age,
they do.
You're not going to,
you're not going to fool me.
There's no mystery.
I know,
I know to an extent,
there's a lot to learn,
but I know who I am.
I know what I'm supposed to do and I know why.
And that's a nice place to come to that.
It's one of the reasons I love standup so much,
by the way.
It's kind of one of the things that I think is wonderful.
It's a privilege I feel,
cause I get to express myself in an original way.
And that never,
that challenge never goes away and it's always changing.
It's one of the things that you know is fun like you and I go do the road.
One of the bonding experience.
I know you feel the same way as when you want your friend growing as an artist
growing in his self expression and constantly changing and having to change and,
and,
and being relevant to whatever's going on it with you at the time
and having the ability to be a generous,
loving,
open pals.
Were you not worried about the other people getting success competition?
There's a lot of that in the artistic communities and whether it's music or
whether it's comedy,
there's a lot of that and I think one of the best things that we've ever done is
sort of eliminate that from our entire group of people.
Like we have an amazing group of people,
whether it's already or Joey or Dunkin or red band or all these people that were
hanging around with that are up there and they're there.
They're doing things like we are all having fun together,
right?
Like,
no one is like,
you know,
he brings their own talent to the stage.
Thompson Thompson girl was brilliant man.
You know,
there's,
there's so many,
there's so many good guys now and to have all the Hinchcliffe Tony Hinchcliffe
so hilarious guy.
I worked with him Sunday night at uh,
Ontario.
He's fucking hilarious.
He's constantly working to,
these guys are constantly working with growing and when you have like a group
like that,
they,
like everybody inside
grows everybody.
Everybody's at Synnex city.
It's not like there's a pie.
You have the bigger piece.
There's no scarcity.
That's where people I think fallen the,
into trouble where they think of the,
of the world as a Pi and he's got this much,
that means I don't have as much.
It's not true at all.
It's a great point.
That's a great point.
And that you're,
that you're one of the best at describing that,
that,
that mindset and you've never had that mindset.
It's one of the reasons why B,
we've been good friends from the moment that we met.
I just,
I knew there's,
you don't have any Duchenne.
You No,
no,
no.
Because I look at it as an inspiration.
So if I see a friend of mine,
it becomes very successful.
You know,
when I watch,
uh,
what the success you've,
you've created for yourself.
To me it's very inspirational.
I that jealousy doesn't ever play a role in it and jealousy is in fact is a
false emotion.
And you,
you can have it.
We all have,
we all want something that you would get worried about your own accomplishment.
When you see somebody being really good,
you're like,
oh,
I'm being lazy.
But just you got to approach that energy in a different way,
right?
That energy is going to be there no problem.
And you could also be,
it's a good thing.
Yes,
it is a good thing.
You could look at yourself unfavorably,
you know,
and that's where the gel is.
Don't let the energy,
don't let that energy.
Don't let that energy say fuck that guy.
He's just lucky.
He's just good at playing politics.
Never helps you.
And it's a lot.
Yes,
it is a lie.
And even if it isn't a lie,
who cares what Catherine to do with you?
Who Cares?
If you see a guy and that guy hit the lottery and got on a TV show and you know
it was like friends or something like that,
not friends,
but you know one of those kind of shows and then all of a sudden he's doing
headlining clubs and he really shouldn't be on stage at all.
What do you give a fuck cares?
Who Cares?
You know?
You know what?
You know what happens to me if I see somebody who's really good?
First of all,
I spend my time with people that are good and I watched my friend kicking ass
like,
you are sick or something like that.
I get so pumped.
It just says,
it says to me,
I feel like I'm in the right company.
These people are inspiring me to move forward and keep.
I want to see what I'm capable of.
Discovery and invention is what separates human beings from animals.
As a creator,
you know you are.
The beautiful thing about your act is that you're creating something.
What I always said to you when I first met you,
I was like,
why are you not like putting more emphasis into your standing?
I'm like,
first of all,
you're trying to do what these guys want you to do.
You're doing this weird alternative thing.
We were being like real like unthreatening on stage.
You weren't being yourself.
And I was like,
this is weird.
And then you're always constantly politicking for your next Gig and your primary
Gig.
Like you were looking for the primary Gig and I was like,
Jesus Christ,
your primary gigs right here,
standing on the acting.
You didn't do comedy for a long time.
Eight years.
That is so fucking crazy to me.
It's so crazy.
We were friends during that time.
No,
I never did standup.
I didn't just do it.
Send them again.
So it was like 36 or so.
It's so weird to me,
man,
because you were always so funny.
You know?
Now what I see,
you know,
and then I'm just,
uh,
you know about to shoot my second hour here.
It's just,
it's,
and things start to Gel.
I can't believe I spent so much time not doing it and can't imagine my life.
You need to listen to me more bitch.
I know.
I,
by the way,
I'll tell you what,
I'll be in Houston.
I'll be in Houston Improv then Buffalo,
uh,
and then Calgary.
I'm all over the place.
Go to Brian
cowen.com and you'll see,
you'll see my schedule.
You'll see my schedule.
You're like,
you're doing some really funny,
weird shit on stage right now.
Mass party.
You're hitting your stride,
right?
If you can tell you've been doing all these sets,
that's really what it's all about.
Yeah.
That's one of the things about um,
doing clubs as opposed to doing theaters.
I'm liking doing five sets in a weekend.
All right.
Once you get in comedy shaped though,
you got to get in comedy shape.
You've got to get used to doing those long sets in because it's so crucial.
Yeah.
Because you've got to be really like,
especially with second shows like second show,
Saturday night,
you gotta be real careful on your set list because you can get lost in what
you've done and haven't done cause it shows start merging together.
They start like they start becoming one show.
It's real weird.
Yup.
I have got to run to go do the fighter and the kid podcast.
I've got to do another podcast.
And if I don't,
that's granite shop will take a big warm hand in my face and I don't want to
deal with that.
Don't let them do that because I have to be there by three 30.
You'll forgive me quite large hands.
Yeah.
Let's end this,
um,
Houston Improv.
Brian Callan is available this weekend.
You freaks.
So,
uh,
let the free party rollout to the Houston Improv and support and I guarantee
you,
you will laugh your dick off.
I have a told people about you for many,
many years of course.
But um,
lately on Twitter I've been getting a lot of tweets of people that went to your
show and had a fucking blast.
Thanks buddy.
So,
uh,
and we're,
we're going to schedule some dates.
We're going to do some yes,
we are future too.
Like we just did.
Yes.
Ryan and I A,
we've worked together a couple times now Vegas and we're so stupid.
We,
why did we wait this long?
Why?
It's only done total blast.
Let's go.
And why did we wait this dark at like three in the morning?
It was amazing.
Legal zoom.com uh,
use the codeword Rogan,
uh,
and thank you to legal zoom.com.
Thanks.
Also to stamps.com use the code word r e for your special offer and thanks to
[inaudible] dot com that's o n n.
O.
N.
I.
T.
He used a codeword brogue and save 10% off any and all sub events.
We will be back tomorrow Thursday with my boy Justin.
Call it from the actual report.com and uh,
we'll see you then until then.
Big Kiss.
All right.
Later.
Okay.